GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION- WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO THE CALL THE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WHO MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING THAT
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. THEM WILL
USING A TELECONFERENCE HOOVER'S
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL WHICH INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN TWO FIVE FIVE
THREE SEVEN SIX FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WILL
BE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR DOT ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. AND OPPOSITION.
PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPRATOR TO
SIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. WHAT YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT
TIME YOU'LL BE A MUTED AND YOU
ARE NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY IN AVOIDING- STICK
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE. THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS. IT IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME
LIKE TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING. TO THE NEW USE
OF ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL OF
PATIENTS WITH ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES. CAN BE HEARD. TODAY WE
HAVE- TWENTY SIX BILLS ON THE
AGENDA HOWEVER FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE. HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATIONS ON
THE BILLS LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. WE HAVE A CORE. WE DO
NOT YET- SO WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE
WILL- BEGIN AS A- COMMITTEE.
ABOUT ITS COMMITTEE SKEWS ME-
JUST WE'LL JUST BEGIN- AND THEN
WE'LL- CALL- CALL ON THE BILL
SO- WHY DON'T WE ASK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CELLO- GOOD
MORNING SIR BEFORE WE BEGIN I
WANT TO QUICKLY SUMMARIZE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
AGREED UPON THE AMENDMENTS
WOULD DELETE MOST OF THE
REQUIREMENTS ON VENDORS. AND
INSTEAD ENCOURAGE VENDORS TO
INCLUDE AN ASSESSMENT REPORT
FOR THE USE OF THAT EIGHTY S.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE A
COMPREHENSIVE INVENTORY OF ALL
HIGH RISK EDA USED DEVELOPER
PROCURED BY THE PUBLICATION
SEES THESE AMENDMENTS ARE
SUMMARIZED ON PAGEFOURTEEN OF
THE ANALYSIS COMMITTEE STAFF IS
ALSO PROVIDED MOCKUP AMENDMENTS
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBER STAFF-
THE SURVEY NUMBER TELL YOU MAY
BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM TO AB
THIRTEEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN AND SENATORS FIRST
FALL IN MAY BEGIN BY THANKING
YOU AND YOUR TEAM FOR WORKING
WITH US SO THE LAST FEW WEEKS
ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL- AB
THIRTEEN WOULD SET FORTH
CRITERIA FOR THE PROCUREMENT OF
HIGH RISK AUTOMATED DECISION
SYSTEMS UP BY GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES IN ORDER TO MINIMIZE
THE RISK OF ADVERSE AND
DISCRIMINATORY IMPACTS
RESULTING FROM THEIR DESIGN AND
APPLICATION. THE USE OF
ALGORITHM DRIVEN AUTOMATED
DECISION SYSTEMS OR EIGHTY S.
CAN ASSIST WITH CREDIT
DECISIONS EMPLOYMENT SCREENING
INSURANCE ELIGIBILITY MARKETING
AND DELIVERY OF GOVERNMENT
SERVICES JUST TO NAME A FEW
HOWEVER A PULLEY DESIGN ET
ESSES CAN ALSO CREATE UNFAIR
BIASED AND INACCURATE RESULTS
CAUSING DISPROPORTIONATE HARM
TO LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHILE ALSO
UNDERMINING TRUST IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR. THEREFORE WHEN IT COMES
TO ACQUISITION OF THE SYSTEMS
BY GOVERNMENT AGENCIES WE MUST
EXAMINE THE STATE'S PROCUREMENT
POLICIES GOVERNMENT ENTITIES
NEED TO CONSIDER IMPORTANT
POLICY CHOICES INHERENT IN
MACHINE LEARNING SYSTEMS
INSTEAD OF TREATING PURCHASES
AS NORMAL GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTING DECISIONS WHICH
SOLELY FOCUS ON PRICE BIDDING
PROCESS INNOVATION AND
COMPETITION. THEY SHOULD ALSO
EXAMINE THE GOALS THAT I. AND
RISK INVOLVED IN SENSE.
OTHERWISE GOVERNMENTS MAY FAIL
IN THEIR RESPONSIBILITY TO MEET
THE PUBLIC EXPECTATIONS OF
OVERSIGHT OF OUR GROUP MAKE
DECISION MAKING AND MAY
INADVERTENTLY CREATE NEW REST
ALL HARMS. LET ME SHARE SOME
EXAMPLES WERE POORLY DESIGNED
AND POORLY UNDERSTOOD PUBLIC
SECTOR OFFERING MAKE. SYSTEMS
HAVE CAUSED HARM TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. IN
MICHIGAN IN AN EMPLOYMENT
AUTHORIZATION WRONGFULLY
ACCUSED FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
OF FRAUD FORCING MANY OF THEM
TO PAY HEAVY FINES. DECLARE
BANKRUPTCY OR HAVE THEIR HOMES
FORECLOSED UPON. AN ARKANSAS
MEDICAID RECIPIENTS LOST ACCESS
TO HOME CARE NURSING VISITS AND
MEDICAL TREATMENTS BECAUSE OF
ERRORS IN HAND IN ERIC
INACCURACIES IN AN AUGER THEM.
IN DETROIT A MARKET ANALYSIS
OTHER THAN USED TO DIRECT
PUBLIC HOUSING SUBSIDIES TAX
BREAKS AND HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
RE DIRECTED CRITICAL FUNDING
AWAY FROM DETROIT'S POOREST AND
PREDOMINANTLY BLACK
NEIGHBORHOODS. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS REPORTED THAT
CALLED WRITERS IN CORRECTLY
TRANSLATED POLICY INTO
CALIFORNIA'S AUTOMATED PUBLIC
BENEFITS SYSTEM KNOWN AS CAL
WIN CAUSING OVERPAYMENTS
UNDERPAYMENTS AND IMPROPER
TERMINATIONS OF PUBLIC
BENEFITS. FOR INSTANCE CAROLYN
DENYING MEDICAID TO FOSTER
CHILDREN IN VIOLATION OF
FEDERAL LAW. I RECENTLY
OPERATIVES HAVE BEEN USED IN
THE ALLOCATION OF VACCINES SO
IT IS IMPORTANT TO ESTABLISH
CLEAR GUIDELINES ON HOW TO
ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY
TRANSPARENCY AND EXPLAINED THE
ABILITY OF THE SYSTEMS
SPECIFICALLY AS PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED AND COMEDIAN ALICE'S AS
A TECH LEADER BY CHERRY SELL.
THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY TO ONE
IDENTIFY WHICH EIGHTY S. S. ARE
HIGH RISK AND INTENDED TARGETS
OF THE BUILD TO CONDUCT AN
INVENTORY OF ALL HIGH RISK EDS
IS THAT HAVE BEEN PROPOSED FOR
OR ARE BEING USED. DEVELOP OR
PROCURE BY PUBLIC AGENCIES
THREE ENCOURAGE A PROSPECTIVE
CONTRACTOR TO SUBMIT AN
AUTOMATED DECISION SYSTEMS
IMPACT ASSESSMENT REPORT OR
SIMPLY A I. EIGHT TO EVALUATE
THE PRIVACY AND SECURITY RISKS
TO PERSONNEL PERSONAL
INFORMATION AND RISKS THAT MAY
RESULT IN AN ACT. YOU NOT ONLY
THE INADEQUATE UNFAIR AND
BIASED OR DISCRIMINATORY
DECISIONS IMPACTING INDIVIDUALS
FOR REQUIRED THE STATE AGENCY
AWARDING A CONTRACT TO PROVIDE
A COPY OF THE IMPACT ASSESSMENT
INCLUDE THE EXTENT TO WHICH
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HAVE
ACCESS TO THE RESULTS IN A ABLE
TO CORRECT. OR OBJECT TO THE
RESULTS AND FINALLY MAKE THE
REPORT AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC
ON LINE TO THE DECIDES TO DO
SO. AS NOTED BY THE WORLD
ECONOMIC FORUM GOVERNMENTS DO
NOT HAVE THE LATTER TWO OF
USING THE BLACK BOX ALGORITHMS
THAT INCREASINGLY CHARACTERIZED
LOGARITHMS DEPLOYED IN THE
MARKETPLACE GOVERNMENT HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO ENSURE
THAT THE SYSTEMS DO NOT CREATE
NEW HARMS BUT ESPECIALLY WHEN
THEY POSE A SIGNIFICANT RISK.
TO THE LEGAL RIGHTS HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF INDIVIDUALS OR
OTHERWISE HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
RESULT IN UNFAIR UNITED IN
ADEQUATE. INACCURATE BIASED OR
DISCRIMINATORY DECISIONS.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK SIMPLY- MA'AM-
I BELIEVE YOU I ADMIT AND MOVE
ON TO ANYONE TO WANTING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE- VINCENT LEE ON THE
COASTLINE TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT.
OPERATOR CAN WE PUT- THERE. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE PROCEED.
L. R. GOOD MORNING CHECK
NUMBERS- YEAH AS AS NOTED MY
NAME VINCENT LEI FROM THE GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE WHERE MY JOB
IS TO ENSURE THAT TECHNOLOGY
WORKS TO CLOSE THE RACIAL
WEALTH GAP AND BUILD ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY. THE USE OF A. I.
IN GOVERNMENT IS EXPELLING. YET%
ONLY 30% OF AMERICANS ARE
CONFIDENT THAT THE GOVERNMENT
IS UP TO THE TASK OF MANAGING A-
THEY'RE PICKING UP ON IT
SOMETHING MENTIONED HERE TODAY
THERE'S A DISTINCT LACK OF
OVERSIGHT AND TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE IN THE GOVERNMENT.
ESPECIALLY AROUND THIS ISSUE.
DID YOU DID IN FACT TAKE WHAT
HAPPENED IN MICHIGAN. AT THE
TIME LIMITS HOW DATED OVER
FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE WRONGLY
ACCUSED OF UNEMPLOYMENT FRAUD.
BUT WHAT YOU DON'T KNOW IN
BALCOMBE COPPER STATE FORTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
PURCHASE AND WHAT HAPPENED
AFTER. WITH A CLASS ACTION
LAWSUIT THE HEAD OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT AGENCY WAS FIRED
MICHIGAN HAD A RETURN SIXTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS OF THOSE
AFFECTED. AND THROUGHOUT ALL OF
THIS. THE AGENT IN CHARGE OF
MANAGING THE SYSTEM AT LITTLE
OR NO IDEA HOW THE ALGORITHM
WORKS OR WHAT WENT WRONG. YOU
HAVE. TO TEST IT WOULD HELP
PREVENT THE BALCONY. AND IT
SHOWS WHY WE A THIRTEEN. WE
DON'T WANT THAT IN CALIFORNIA
AT THIRTEEN AS A WAY TO BUILD
TRUST IN A. I. IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS IN A WAY TO
PROTECT VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
ARE BEING HARMED BY EDS. AN
INCORRECT ASSUMPTION OR FAULTY
AND BIASED. THE PUBLIC TRUST IS
ALL THEMORE IMPORTANT AS WE
SEEK TO MODERNIZE AND IMPROVE
GOVERNMENT SERVICES. THEIR
PROPOSAL TO CREATE AN ACCOUNT
UNDER THE BETTER TERM AND
PATIENT ACCESS TO CARE. ALL
AGENCIES INCLUDING THE FACT
THAT MEN ARE TURNING TO
SOLUTIONS LIKE BOB DOT A. I. TO
CONNECT COMMUNITY MEMBERS WITH
HOUSING VOUCHERS. BUT PRECLUDE
COMMUNITY TRUST THEN THE
POLLUTION ARE LOT LESS VIABLE
WE CAN BEAT IT AS WITH THE
PASSAGE OF PROP TWENTY FIVE.
WHICH BANNED LAW ENFORCEMENT-
USING PRETRIAL RISK ASSESSMENT
TOOL ENTIRELY BECAUSE THE
PUBLIC HAD LOST TRUST IN THE.
SYSTEM WE DON'T WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN ELSEWHERE. EIGHTY
THIRTEEN AND MUCH SUCH A- OF
MEDIA IT ONLY APPLIES TO
GOVERNMENT PROCUREMENT AND ONLY
IN INSTANCES WHERE THE RISK OF
AN IMPACT OF AROUND AT THE
JUNIOR HIGH. VERY SMALL NUMBER
OF VICTIMS. BUT PETER CRITICAL
SYSTEMS THAT DETERMINE ACCESS
THE BENEFITS MEDICAL CARE
EMPLOYMENT OR HOUSING.
FURTHERMORE THE EIGHTY THIRTEEN
IMPACT ASSESSMENT ONLY AFTER
HELPERS TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF HOW THE SYSTEM WORKS TO
THINK THROUGH WHETHER THEY'RE A
I COULD HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. HOW TO MEET HIM
IN HOW TO MINIMIZE THIS RISK.
BUT THESE ARE THINGS THAT
SHOULD BE DISCLOSED TO PUBLIC
AGENCIES AS A MATTER OF COURSE
IN ANY EVENT. AND IT'LL HELP
THEM MAKE WELL INFORMED
PROCUREMENT DECISIONS. ITS
REQUIREMENTS ARE MINIMAL BURDEN
AND WILL NOT PRECLUDE
BUSINESSES FROM PARTICIPATING
IN THE PROCUREMENT PROCESS.
FINALLY WHAT AN INDEPENDENT
COMMITTEE WE HAVE FURTHER NEAR
THE BUILDING IMPACT ASSESSMENT
OPTIONAL MALL ADDING IN A KEY
REQUIREMENT THAT WE TAKE STOCK
OF EXISTING HIGHER THE DAY I AM
CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO NOTE THAT
DOWN THE OPPOSITION MAY NOT BE
SATISFYING AND OPPORTUNITY TO
CONSIDER ALTERNATE AMENDMENT.
THAT WOULD NOT ALLOW AGENCIES
TO GIVE. ADDITIONAL
CONSIDERATION TO BETTER THAT
HAPPENED HE DID IT IN PRACTICE.
WE FELT THAT THE HOW THE
LANGUAGE WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
AGENCIES THAT BENTLEY TO IGNORE
IMPACT ASSESSMENT. OF BUILDER
PUBLIC DUTIES OR HELP BUILD
PUBLIC TRUST THAT THE ARMY
DECISION. THAT WE'RE PAYING FOR
OUR FAIR AND UNBIASED AND
FINALLY I WILL NOTE THE IMPACT
ASSESSMENT FOR HIGH RISK A I'M
I REQUIRE. INFLATED LIKE THE
TWENTY SEVEN MEMBER STATES OF
THE EUROPEAN UNION AND CANADA.
WE BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA
MIGHT FOLLOW IN THE FOOTSTEPS
AND TAKE ACTION TO PROTECT OUR
PEOPLE FROM INACCURATE OR
BIASED HEY I JUST SENT. IN FOR
THESE REASONS. I RESPECTFULLY
AFTER I BOOKED. THANK YOU MR
LAY- NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
A. B. THIRTEEN. SEEING NONE-
WILL MOVE NOW TO WITNESSES IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE AND THERE IS
NOBODY THERE- THANK YOU NOW
WE'LL MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR HIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
THIRTEEN WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR AGAIN TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A. B. ONE THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
THE ZERO. DOWN EIGHTEEN KEY
AFTER YOU WILL GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER ONLINE THANK YOU BACK IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. PUT YOURSELF IN JUDICIAL
SUPPORT FOR A. B. THIRTEEN. OUR
FIRST PARTICIPANT WILL BE LINE
FORTY TWO PLEASE CONTACT. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THE LINE FORTY FIVE. YOUR TURN
MEMBER TOLD ME IN THE LEAST
SHOP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. I AM EIGHTEEN YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING HE TRIMMED WITH
UNITY AND KATRINA CAROLINE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
ELECTRONIC PRIVACY INFORMATION
CENTER OR AFFECT- CALL UNIT
SUPPORT AND A BABY THIRTEEN FOR
ALL THE REASONS. THAT ONE FIVE
THREE ONE INSTITUTE THANK YOU.
WITH THE SUPPORT AT THE FINAL
IN MY TO SHOW. FOR A. B.
THIRTEEN PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME TAKE A SECOND AND THEN
OKAY. AND I MISTER CHAIRMAN NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUE UP.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER CELLO
IF YOU'LL PLEASE EXCUSE US
WE'VE GOT SOME BUSINESS TO DO
HERE WE'RE GOING TO CALL FOR A
QUORUM PLEASE. CONSULTANT DOT
HERE START HERE NILSSON NOTES
IN HERE ALAN ARCHULETA ACTOR
BURGESS. WHAT DOES PRESIDENT
BRADFORD LATER YES PLEASE- HERE
WAS SO THERE WAS- HERE JONES.
CATALOGUER COME OVER HERE
MELENDEZ YEAH BELINDA'S HERE
POURED INTO NOW. HERE TWENTY
NOTE HERE RUBIO. WE ARE PRESENT
WELCOME. CAN WE HAVE A FORM.
THANK YOU THE SECRETARY WILL
NOW MOVE YOUR CONSENT CALENDAR
THERE FOURTEEN BILLS SO THY
CAN SET THEIR FILE OUT OF
NUMBER. 1-561-213-1415. SIXTEEN
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE OF
TWENTY SIX MAY HAVE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. CENTER
CALL MARGARET THANK YOU WE GOT
IT MOTION- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MISSED SECTOR DADA. HI DONNA HI
NELSON OKAY NELSON I ALLEN
ARCHULETA BECKER BORCHERS
BORDERS HI BRADFORD GLAZER HI
PLEASE R. I. WESO. WHY SO HI
JONES. CAN LONGER AND LONGER I
MELENDEZ BELINDA'S I PUT INTO
YOU KNOW. I WANTED TO KNOW I.
RUBIO RUBIO I WILL. THAT'S A
NINE SEVEN PUT ON CALL IT'S GOT
NINE VOTES THAT- THE BILL IS ON
CALL WE'RE BACK IN A. B.
THIRTEEN. YEAH WE'VE HEARD FROM
ALL SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS OF YOUR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE
HAVE SHOW UP- MUHAMMAD IS A
LEAD OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
GALLERY. PLEASE PROCEED SIR.
YES YOUR HONOR. BUT THEY CAN
SURE MEMBERS ARE WE'RE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED AB
THIRTEEN AS WE BELIEVE IT IS AN
EXTREMELY COMPLEX BILL THAT
WILL DISRUPT THE STATE
PROCUREMENT PROCESS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES WITH THIS
BILL IF THE OVERBROAD
DEFINITION OF AUTOMATED
DECISION SYSTEM WHICH APPLIES
TO ANY COMPUTATIONAL PROCESS
THAT IS USED TO SUPPORT HUMAN
DECISION MAKING A MATERIALLY
IMPACTS PERSONS. THE EXCEPTION
UNDER THE BILL READS IN
RELEVANT PART ANYTHING THAT
DOES NOT SUPPORT YOUR DECISION
MAKING AND LIST EXAMPLES THE
EXCEPTION IS EFFECTIVELY A
RESTATEMENT OF THE DEFINITION
FOR THE WORD NOT INSERTED INTO
IT THIS CONFUSING LANGUAGE
CREATES- THAT EXTANT EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING SITUATION TO
IDENTIFYANY COMPETITION
PROCESS BUT BOTH SQUARELY
INSIDE OR OUTSIDE OF THE
DEFINITION IT'S CONSIDERED AN
AUTOMATED DECISION SYSTEMS
EXCEPT FOR THOSE EXCEPTIONS
WHICH ARE SPECIFICALLY
IDENTIFIED IN THE BILL
INCLUDING THINGS LIKE
CALCULATORS AND SPREADSHEETS.
OTHER THAN THESE ITEMS THE BILL
COULD APPLY TO EVERY SOFTWARE
IN USE TODAY. FIRST DAY.
SUBJECT TO THIS BILL WOULD BE
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
CONFIDENTLY DETERMINE WHETHER
THIS EXCEPTION IS INTENDED TO
APPLY TO A CHAT BOT ON A
WEBSITE. SO CREDIT APPLICATION
FOR BENEFITS FOR STANDARDIZED
TESTING SYSTEM. THE SAME
CHALLENGE PLUS BUSINESS OWNERS
WERE BIDDING ON STATE CONTRACTS
AND TRYING TO DETERMINE WHAT IS
INCLUDED IN THE DEFINITION OF
IT YES. THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
BUSINESS TO AUDITED SYSTEMS AS
A PREREQUISITE TO SUCCESSFULLY
SUBMITTING A BID. AND A
CONTRACTOR CANNOT AFFORD TO FOR
PAY SOMEONE TO. BE DENIED
PARTICIPATION IN THE STATE
PROJECT BIDDING PROCESS THE
BID. NOT TO CONSIDER. FOR
COLLISION SHARES NOBLE
OBJECTIVE OF COMBATING BIAS AND
DISCRIMINATION BUT AB THIRTEEN
EVEN AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED.
IT'S NOT A SQUEEZE THESE
CONCERNS WE ASK YOU TO VOTE NO
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR MOHAMMED- IS THERE
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE GALLERY
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS- IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE WILL
MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE- SEE
NOBODY IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATE
IF YOU PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY.
IN OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN.
THANK YOU AGAIN TO SHOW UP AS-
TO AB THIRTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE WILL
BEGIN WITH WIND THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS CAME INTO
MAINSTREAM A TECHNICIAN IN
RESPECT OPTICIAN AB. THIRTEEN
NINE FORTY YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING JUSTIN HIGHER ON BEHALF
OF THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP WE MUST ALSO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
KAREN MEMBERS NAMELY THE DRONE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CREDIT UNION LEAGUE ALSO
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
FINE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE FORTY NINE THIS IS THIS
LINE FORTY NINE AM I LYING
FORTY NINE RIGHT NOW- MORNING
PRAYER AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
ANDREA HAD STRONG AND I AM
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED TO ABC
THIRTEEN AND I AM VEHEMENTLY
OPPOSED TO YOUR PHARMACY
TECHNOCRACY THANK YOU NO ON
THIS BILL. I AND WE WILL GO TO
ONE THIRTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING KAREN MEMBERS
STEPHANIE MOORE WHILE ON BEHALF
OF CONSUMER TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION FOR THE- THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY SEVEN EUROPE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MADELEINE KLEIN ON BEHALF OF
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO EITHER KEEP. NINE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
AND AS FOR EVERYBODY ELSE-
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION. FOR A. B.
THIRTEEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD
THIRTY EIGHT. I DON'T OFTEN ON
BEHALF OF INTERNET ASSOCIATION
RESPECTIVELY COMPARED TO
THIRTEEN THANK YOU. AND NEXT IS.
ONE THIRTY FIVE. THIRTY FIVE
YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING.
FROM THE COUNTY AND. AND MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANT CANADA. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SHE DIED- THIS DROP
MODERATOR THANK YOU- THANK YOU
TO ALL OUR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL NOW BRING THIS
BACK TO FOR DISCUSSION FOR THE
MEMBERS ANY MEMBERS WISHING TO.
RAISE ANY ISSUES QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SENATOR MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN- SO-
THANK YOU SIR MY MEMBER CHOW
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AND I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
WITH THIS BILL. FROM BUT THERE
ARE A COUPLE OF ISSUES. THAT I
HAVE- ONE BEING THAT I THINK
THIS IS GOING TO BE COST
PROHIBITIVE FOR- A NUMBER OF
SMALL BUSINESSES PARTICULARLY
THOSE THAT ARE VETERAN OWNED
AND MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES
TO THE POINT WHERE. THEY WON'T
BE ABLE TO AFFORD THIS TYPE OF
REPORTING WHICH MEANS WE'E
GOING TO BE USHERING CORPORATE
IS CORPORATISM INTO. THIS ARENA
AND PUSHING OUT THE LITTLE GUY
AND I HAVE A LOT OF CONCERN
ABOUT THAT- THE- THE OTHER ONE
IS I GUESS. ISN'T IT I GUESS
THE PROBLEM WITH THESE BUY
SEEDS IS MORE- THE PEOPLE.
DEVELOPING THESE PROGRAMS AND
PUTTING YOU INSERTING THIS
TECHNOLOGY INTO THAT IT
DETECTS. OR INTERPRETED BY
SEASON CERTAINLY IT'S NOT THE
MACHINERY ITSELF IN OTHER WORDS
NOTHING AND NUTS AND BOLTS IT'S
THE PEOPLE. BEHIND IT AND I'M
NOT SURE YOU SEE THAT. THE BILL
ADDRESSES THAT WOULD YOU CARE
TO- COMMENTER CLARIFY THAT.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR QUESTIONS US SENATOR I
THINK- ANYTIME WE TALK ABOUT
THE COST OF A PRODUCT FOR
EXAMPLE. A WE SHOULD DEFINITELY
ARE CONSIDERED THE POSSIBILITY
THAT WHEN STATE AGENCIES
PURCHASE THESE PRODUCTS OR
SYSTEMS ARE EDS SYSTEMS. AT A
COST THAT IT WOULD BEEN CURVE
TO THE GENERAL POPULATION IF
THE SYSTEMS CONTAIN ANY BIASES
OR DISCRIMINATORY. IMPACT HE
HAD PROBLEM WITH. SOME OF THE
SYSTEMS IS THAT THEY OPERATE AS
BLACK BOXES NOBODY REALLY KNOWS
WHAT GOES INTO THE BLACK BOX.
AND THEY USE THESE SYSTEMS
MOSTLY ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
SYSTEMS THEY PUT DATA IN THAT
THEY PUT BIG DATA SO TO SPEAK
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
ANALYTICS. AND THEY PRODUCE AN
OUTCOME THAT WOULD HELP THEM
MAKE DECISIONS. THE PROBLEM IS
YOU KNOW THE SYSTEMS NOBODY
REALLY KNOWS WHAT THEY DO. AND
WHAT WE TRY TO DO IS TO SHINE
SOME LIGHT ON THESE BLACK BOXES
AND THE IMPACT ASSESSMENT THAT
WE'RE ASKING THEM TO DO IS
ESSENTIALLY. TO HOW INTEL IS
WHAT THESE SYSTEMS DO HOW THEY
OPERATE WHAT THE PICK A
CAPABILITIES ARE WHAT THE
LIMITATIONS ARE AND WHETHER OR
NOT TO DISCRIMINATE WILL CREATE
BIASES. YOU'RE RIGHT I THINK A
LOT OF THESE DECISIONS GOOD
COLIN. ARE FROM HUMAN BEINGS
SIX SIX PEOPLE HAVE BIASES IN
GENERAL BUT WE- WHAT WE TRY TO
DO IS TO ACTUALLY ASK HIM TO
TELL US WHETHER OR NOT THE
SCHISMS CREATE BIASES. AND HOW
WE SHOULD ALSO ARE YOU KNOW
ANALYZE IT FROM THE STATE
AGENCY'S PERSPECTIVE FOR
EXAMPLE IF A STATE AGENCY WANTS
TO PROCURE A SYSTEM THAT WILL
PUT TEN. POTENTIALLY IMPACT
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE DON'T YOU
WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOUR PRODUCT
ALL THE PRODUCTS ARE AND WHAT
THEY CAN AND CANNOT DO IN ORDER
NOT TO CREATE BIASES AND
DISCRIMINATION ON YOUR P. O. ON
ON THE GENERAL POPULATION. AND
EXAMPLES. THAT I GAVE EARLIER
FOR EXAMPLE TO MICHIGAN SENERE.
WERE HE ARE UNDER THE AGE OF
SYSEM. FOR THOUSAND PEOPLE. US
BENEFITS B. TWO B. ALL IMPACTED
NEGATIVELY AN- ACCOUNT. WHAT
RESULTED WAR S. ACE WHO YOUR
SERIES OF LAWSUITS AND- THAT
YOU KNOW WERE BROUGHT AGAINST
THE GOVERNMENT AND THE
GOVERNMENT ENDED UP HAVING TO
PAY A LOT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
TO BASICALLY SETTLE THESE
LAWSUITS SO THAT'S ONLY ONE
EXAMPLE OF THE FOUR EXAMPLES
SO. SO I THINK WE NEED TO LOOK
AT THE YOU KNOW THE COST FACTOR
YOU'RE NOT JUST LOOKING AT THE
YOU KNOW THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT
DID PREPARE IS IN AND- AND THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT WE NEED TO LOOK
AT THE LONG. RANGE THE RISKS
INVOLVED ALSO. I HOPE THAT YOUR
QUESTION. WELL YOU YOU
CERTAINLY PROVIDED SOME USEFUL
INFORMATION I DO APPRECIATE
THAT ALTHOUGH I DON'T KNOW THAT
WE PUT A FINER POINT ON THE
ISSUE OF IT BEING COST
PROHIBITIVE TO SOME OF THE
SMALLER BETTER KNOWN TO
MINORITY BUSINESSES BUT- BUT I
APPRECIATE- YOUR RESPONSE TO
SOME WOMEN THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. THE SENATOR FROM
LAGER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I TOO
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS AND
I CAME IN LATE FROM ANOTHER
HEARING SO- I MAY HAVE MISSED.
SOME OF THIS BUT THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE TAKEN MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT. DO THAT
AND AMENDMENTS AMENDMENTS
MANDATE THE IMPACT ASSESSMENT
OR JUST ASK FOR I. WASN'T CLEAR
IF IT REQUIRES IT OR NOT I KNOW
WELL WITH THE AMENDMENTS THE
VENDORS ARE NOT OBLIGATED TO
PROVIDE THESE REPORTS THEY ARE
ENCOURAGED TO PROVIDE THEM ONTO
THE STATE AGENCIES ACCORDINGLY.
SO WHAT WHAT END UP HAPPENING
IS THAT STATE AGENCIES OR STATE
CDT IN PARTICULAR WILL COME UP
WITH GUIDELINES AND ABOUT THESE
ATS SYSTEMS FOR VENDORS TO
COMPLY WITH AND THEY WILL ALSO
COME UP WITH A SAMPLE FORM IF
THEY SO DESIRE TO SUBMIT THESE
IMPACT ASSESSMENT REPORT. SO
ESSENTIALLY THEY ARE THEY ARE-
THESE ARE VOLUNTARY COMPLIANCE-
AS OPPOSED TO THE ORIGINAL
VERSION OF THE BILL WHICH
MANDATED COMPLIANCE. RIGHT SO
IF. THEY DON'T COMPLY AND
DECIDE NOT TO USE THE
GUIDELINES. THEN WHAT HAPPENS
THE THING I DON'T UNDERSTAND
YOUR THE GOAL IS TO HELP
IDENTIFY. MAYBE THE BIAS SEES
IN THESE AI SYSTEMS BUT IF YOU
HAVE ANDERS AND DECIDED NOT TO
COMPLY BECAUSE IT'S NOT
MANDATORY FEDERAL ENFORCEMENT
THEN WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
OUTCOME OF NOTHING HAPPENS TO
THE OUTCOME- WE SIMPLY
ENCOURAGING A DC YOU KNOW STATE
AGENCIES TO- TO LOST AND
CREATING THE VENDORS TO. TO
PROVIDE THESE REPORTS TO THE
STATE AGENCIES WHEN THEY ARE.
ON A PARTICULAR CONTRACT OUT
FOR EXAMPLE TWO HERE'S ANOTHER
OPPONENT THERE'S ANOTHER PIECE
TO THE AMENDMENT THAT IS THE
INVENTORY PEAS SO UNDER THE
AMENDMENTS OF C. T. IS SUPPOSED
TO COME UP WITH A COMPREHENSIVE
INVENTORY OF ALL THESE VIDEO
SYSTEMS THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE
OR INTEND TO PURCHASE I'M SO
THAT WAY WE HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT. THE
UNIVERSE IS OUT THERE. ON SO
THAT WE COULD TAKE ACTION
ACCORDINGLY. OKAY THANK YOU AND
THEN- YOU KNOW I'M GLAD THAT
ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO
TESTIFIED- I GUESS ONE OF THE
SUPPORTERS MENTIONED APPROX
TWENTY FIVE AND THERE WAS A LOT
OF DISCUSSION AROUND. THAT
PARTICULAR PROPOSITION BECAUSE
OF THE RISK ASSESSMENT TOOLS
AND- THE ALGORITHMS THAT ARE
USED IN THOSE ASSESSMENTS. AND
THE POINT WHICH I THINK- MIGHT
HAVE BEEN RAISED EARLIER AND I
CERTAINLY HAVE BEEN THINKING
ABOUT. IS THAT- YOU KNOW
ALGORITHMS ARE. FROM A PURELY
ANALYTICAL- SPACE ARE UNBIASED
BUT IT'S THE CODERS WHO ARE
CREATING THE ALGORITHMS THAT
INTEGRATE THE BIAS OF THE
PREJUDICE INTO THE ALGORITHMS
THAT ARE THEN USED AND THEN YOU
KNOW PURCHASED BY GOVERNMENTS
PEOPLE CONSUMERS X. CETERA. AND
HOW DOES THIS GET BACK THAT AND
THE REASON WHY I ASK BECAUSE
ACTUALLY BECAUSE THERE WAS AN
ARTICLE THAT JUST CAME OUT THIS
MORNING THAT WAS TALKING ABOUT
THE TECH INDUSTRY AND A
KNOWLEDGE AND HOW INCREDIBLY
HOMOGENOUS- THE INDUSTRY IS
LESS THAN 1% OF FOLKS WHO ARE
CODING. ARE IN FACT AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND SO IF WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT HOW TO CREATE
EQUITY IN THESE KINDS OF A. I.
SYSTEMS THAT THEN WE ARE
BECOMING MORE AND MORE
DEPENDENT UPON DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
WORKING TO DIVERSIFY. FROM AN
ETHNICITY FROM RACIAL FROM A
GENDER LENS THANK THE FOLKS WHO
ARE ACTUALLY CODING. AND IN
FACT NOW THAT WE HAVE ENTERED
INTO A SPACE WITH HYBRIDIZED-
WORKPLACES WHERE YOU CAN WORK
FROM HOME THERE'S ACTUALLY NO
NEED TO OPEN UP A COMPANY IN
PROBLEM AND AN INTEGRATED CITY
AND THEN HIRE FROM THAT WORK
FORCE WHICH WOULD ENSURE THAT
YOU WOULD HAVE AN INTEGRATED-
WORKFORCE WORKING FOR YOU. SO
DOES GET OUT THERE BECAUSE I'M
WONDERING HOW MUCH. HOW MUCH
PROGRESS ARE WE MAKING YOUR FOR
INVENTORYING. INFORMATION
VERSUS THE PROGRESS WE COULD
MAKE IT FOR ACTUALLY TRYING TO
IMPACT HOW CODES ARE BEING
DEVELOPED WHO ARE THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE CODING. AND THEN HOW
THOSE PURCHASES HAPPEN. YEAH
THOSE ARE EXCELLENT
OBSERVATIONS OF MR IF I MAY DO
FOR THE QUESTION TO- MY WITNESS
WHO HAS MORE EXPERTISE IN THIS
AREA TO RESPOND TO THESE-
OBSERVATIONS. PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU YES HELLO THE IMPACT
THAT THAT DOES HAPPEN THE
COMPANY'S IT IS AGAIN OPTIONAL-
IT DOES ASK THE COMPANY THERE
AT THE MEETING IT WHAT
PROPERTIES THEY HAVEN'T PLAYED-
OR POLICY THAT THEY HAVE TO
ADDRESS THAT BUYERS ARE
INACCURACY OF THEIR A. I.
SYSTEMS THE DEADLY BEING YOU
KNOW A COMPANY THAT HAS A
DIVERSE SET OF FOLDERS WE'LL BE
ABLE TO TALK ABOUT THAT IN
THEIR IMPACT ASSESSMENT- AND
YOU KNOW THEY COULD ALSO TALK
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THEY HAVE
TESTED THEIR SYSTEM- AND ALSO.
I THINK A KEY PART OF WHAT THE
IMPACT ASSESSMENT DOES HE HELLO
THE DEBATE AGENCY WHAT IS- THAT
DEVELOPERS CONCEPTION OF
FAIRNESS HOW DO THEY DEFINE THE
POLICY ON HOW WE TREAT A FAIR
DECISION. AND IMPORTANT EVENT
IN IN IN WHEN YOU'RE PREPARING
TO DEFEND ITS GONNA AFFECT
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE AND THEN TO
YOU IN ADDITIONAL POINT IS THAT
WOULD BE IMPACTED THAT OUR
CLIENTS AREN'T HOT IT IS JUST
THE DOCUMENTATION PARTS OF
SMALL BUSINESSES MY ONLY
MINORITY ON ONE VETERAN ON ONE
CAN FILL OUT THE IMPACT
INVESTMENT JUST FINE AND IT
DOESN'T ACTUALLY MANDATE ANY
EXPENSIVE. AUDITING OR ANYTHING
OF THE SORT. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS AND GENDER COME ALIVE
OR- Q. THAT DOES ANSWER MY
QUESTIONS. SENATOR BETTER THANK
YOU THAT INCIDENT AND I KNOW WE
TRIED TO CONNECT ISSUE DID NOT-
I WANTED TO ASK ME ALL THESE
DEPARTMENTS. THEY HAVE
PROCUREMENT DEPARTMENT WHOSE
JOB IT IS TO EVALUATE. ALL
TYPES OF SOFTWARE. WHY IS THIS
BILL NEEDED IN YOUR MIND. WHAT
THE FOCUS IS ON THE- HIGH RISK
APPLICATIONS ARE THAT ARE BEING
DEPLOYED BY STATE AGENCIES AND
CD T. INTERN IS T.
ORGANIZATIONAL AGENCIES AGENCY
THAT ON THAT OVERSEES THE
PURCHASE OF I. T. PRODUCTS IN
GENERAL- AND WHICH IS THE
REASON WHY WE'RE ASKING C. D.
T. TO CONDUCT THE INVENTORY. OF
ALL THE SO BASICALLY THESE ARE
I. T. PRIDE OF PROJECTS. RIGHT
BUT I MEAN. YOU SHOULDN'T DATE
PARTY I MEAN WE'VE USED CAR
LOTS OF SOFTWARE FOR LOTS OF
IMPORTANT. PRIORITIES FOR THE
STATE AND SHOULD THEY ISN'T
BASICALLY THEIR JOB TO TAKE ALL
THESE THINGS INTO ACCOUNT
ANYWAY RATHER THAN CREATING
ANOTHER REPORTING. THE
SITUATION IS THAT PEOPLE HAVE
RAISED MIGHT BE PROBLEMATIC FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES AND OTHERS
RIGHT I THINK GOD. WHEN IT
COMES TO PROCUREMENT PROCESS I
THINK THERE THERE ARE STILL
SOME UNIFORMITY AMONGST ALL THE
STATE AGENCIES BUT YET THERE
ARE SOME DEVIATION. AS WELL OF
IT VARIATIONS AS WELL SO- YOU
KNOW US SOME AGENCIES MAY
REQUIRE REPORTING OF CERTAIN
FEATURES ABOUT THE PRODUCT LINE
OR WHAT THE DEAL TO. SEE YOU
KNOW THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS
TO BASICALLY CREATE UNIFORMITY
ALSO- PENA BY WAY OF CREATING
THAT FORM THAT SAMPLE FORM THAT
WE'RE PROPOSING IN IN THIS BILL.
WELL I RECKON A JUDGE JOSEPH
MYSELF I APPRECIATE THE VERY
MUCH THE INTENT OF THIS
LEGISLATION HAVE. WORKING LEGAL
TECH I'VE SEEN YOU KNOW THERE
THERE ARE CASES OF BIAS AROUND-
PAROLE AND THINGS LIKE THAT
THE- THAT SOME DECISIONS THAT
WE'VE SEEN- YOU KNOW HOWEVER I
THINK YOU JUST. HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS AROUND THE
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THIS AND
WHETHER YOU CAN IT'S NEEDED AS
MORE PEOPLE ARE JUST REALLY
SHOULD BE JUST DOING THEIR JOBS
TO EVALUATE THE SOFTWARE. SO
PROBABLY LAYING OFF. AT THIS
TIME BUT I'M OPEN TO SUPPORTING
IT DOWN THE ROAD. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OBSERVATIONS OF MEMBERS. THE
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT. THREE
NINE. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE A
SEVEN MEMBER THE WHOLE. WELL
THERE IS. HE RECOGNIZED ME YEP.
THE CHAIRMAN YES IT IS A MY
OPPORTUNITY. GO AHEAD OKAY
SENATOR GLAZER THANK YOU- WELL
I HAVE A COUPLE THINGS FIRST-
SEVEN AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL TO US YOU
KNOW THIS IS AN AREA THAT I'M
NOT THAT FAMILIAR WITH SO I'VE
HAD A LITTLE BIT OF A LEARNING
CURVE AND REVIEWING YOUR BILL
AND IT ALSO GAVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. LOOK AT SOME OF
THE OTHER BILLS THAT HAVE COME
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS- IN GENERAL
TERMS YOU KNOW I I'M A BIG
SUPPORTER OF TECHNOLOGY AND-
YOU KNOW IF YOU IF YOU TALK
ABOUT THE CRITICISMS OF
GOVERNMENTS. ONE OF THE PLACES
THAT I THINK WE ALL RECEIVE
SOME LEVEL OF CRITICISM IS THAT
WE'RE NOT EFFICIENT IN WHAT WE
DO. WE'RE NOT SPENDING
TAXPAYERS MONEY AS EFFICIENTLY
AS WE CAN THAT THE PRIVATE
SECTOR SEEMS TO DO THEIR WORK
BETTER THAN WITHIN WE CAN
WITHIN GOVERNMENT. AND SO I- IN
GENERAL TERMS THAT YOU KNOW. I
LOVE THE TECHNOLOGY- THAT WE
CANNOT DEPLOY IT CERTAINLY
THAT. THE PROBLEMS THAT WE'VE
HAD HERE IN STATE GOVERNMENT IS
THAT. IN IN THE AREA OF I. T.
WE SIMPLY THESE SEEMED TO NOT
REALLY BE ABLE TO GET A PROJECT
DONE ON BUDGET. ON TIME- AND-
THAT CONTINUES TO BE A PROBLEM-
AND I AND I WOULD NOTE THAT
SOMETIMES. IT'S NOT ABOUT BIAS
IT'S JUST A MISTAKE. I MEAN IT
AND MISTAKES WERE MADE ALL THE
TIME. BYE BYE DUBAI HUMAN
PEOPLE ALL THE TIME AND WE AS A
LEGISLATURE STRIVE TO TRY TO.
DEAL WITH THAT AND THAT'S
CERTAINLY- DO OUR BEST TO
ELIMINATE DISCRIMINATION IN ANY
FORM AND PLACE THAT WE COULD
NEVER FIND IT- BUT I DO WANT
TO. ASK YOU WHEN THE WHEN
GOVERNOR NEWSOM VETOED THE
SOLACE BILL CREATING AN I. T.
POSITION IN STATE GOVERNMENT.
TWO YEARS AGO HE HE SAID HE HE
WHAT HE PUNTED THE ISSUE. TO
THE COMMISSION ON THE FUTURE OF
WORK COMMISSION HE SAID I AM
HIS VETO MESSAGE THAT THEY'RE
EXAMINING THE IMPACT OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE- AND- I
WONDER IF YOU'VE HEARD ANY
FEEDBACK FROM THAT COMMISSION
IN THIS SPACE THAT COULD
ENLIGHTEN US. THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR THE QUESTION WE HAVE NOT
HEARD FROM THE COMMISSION PER
SE ALTHOUGH WE- HAVE BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH THE CDT- AND-
WE'VE BEEN IN COMMUNICATION
WITH THEM ABOUT THE BILL ITSELF
AND- WE WANTED TO SEEK THEIR
OPINION AS TO. WHAT HOW THEY
SEE THE BILL SHOULD PROCEED- SO
THAT IS STILL ONGOING- ALTHOUGH
THE COMMISSION ITSELF WE HAVE
NOT HEARD FROM. THANK YOU FOR
SHARING THAT I YOU KNOW I. HI I
GUESS TWO THINGS THAT THE SUM
UP WHERE I AM NOT ON THE ISSUE
ONE IS I THINK THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE CHAIR IS OFFERED-
CREATING PERMISSIVE AND
PERMISSIVE- LANE I THINK IS A
GOOD MAN AND I KNOW IT'S NOT
WHAT YOU WANTED- BUT I DO THINK
THAT THAT IS A THAT IS AN
INCREMENTAL STEP AHEAD THAT
MAKES ME A LITTLE BIT MORE
COMFORTABLE. AND FINALLY I WANT
TO NOTE THAT IN YOUR WITNESS
TODAY TALKED ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
PUBLIC TRUST. AND I CAN'T THINK
OF A MORE IMPORTANT TOUCHSTONE
AND ALL THAT WE DO HERE THE
LEGISLATURES TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE- THAT WE EVER IN THAT
PUBLIC TRUST IN ALL THAT WE
HAVE DONE AND SAY- AND I DO
THINK THAT THIS- KNOWLEDGE IS
THAT. THE CARE THAT WE HAVE TO
HAVE IN THE SPACE OF BIAS AND
DISCRIMINATION- AND IT'S FOR
THOSE REASONS THAT I'M NOT.
GOING TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY. THANKS FOR THE REPORT DO
YOU KNOW. THAT I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BUT
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO SEE HOW IT.
PROGRESSES THROUGH THE SYSTEM
AND- RESERVE THE RIGHT TO
REVISIT THAT BUT I'LL GIVE A
COURTESY VOTE TODAY. VERY GOOD.
AND THE OTHER MEMBERS WITH ANY
QUESTIONS. SENATOR ALAN JUST TO
ASSOCIATE MYSELF BY MYSELF WITH
MY COLLEAGUES AND I WANT TO
GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK ON WHAT I CONSIDER TO BE A
REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE I KNOW
THESE AMENDMENTS YOU'VE TAKEN-
I THINK REALLY DO- ADDRESS A
LOT OF THE CORE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED. BY MY
OPPONENT SO I CERTAINLY MINUTE
ASHA COMFORTABLE VOTING. TO PUT
IN A POSITION TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON THIS. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. WE HAVE CENTER GLACIER
THANK YOU. NONE IS JANET HAPPY
TO MOVE THE BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME WHICH WOULD BE
THE APPROPRIATE TIME YOU DO
HAVE A MOTION IT WOULD BE LIKE
TO GIVE SIR CLOSE IT'LL
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHILD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN ALLOW ME
TO CLOSE TODAY'S DISCUSSION BY
RESPONDING TO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. I FIND
INTERESTING THE OPPOSITION
STATEMENT AT ITS STAND STRONGLY
AGAINST NEGATIVE BIAS AND
DISCRIMINATION BUT HAS MADE NO
EFFORT WHATSOEVER TO PROVIDE US
WITH SPECIFIC LANGUAGE OR
INDUSTRY PRACTICE PRACTICES TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS
INSTEAD OF CONTINUOUSLY POINTS
OUT THE DEFINITION OF ADS IS
BEING OVERLY BROAD WHICH WOULD
NARROW SUBSTANTIALLY TOO ONLY
HIGH RISK APPLICATIONS SO HE
NOW ARGUES THAT THE DEFINITION
OF HIGH RES IS NOT CONFINED TO
THE HIGH RISK APPLICATION AS
NOTED EARLIER THIS BILL DIRECTS
THE DEPARTMENT OF A TECHNOLOGY
TO IDENTIFY WHICH EDS IS OUR
HIGH RISK AND INTENDED TARGETS
OF THE BILL. NOW THIS
REGULATORY PROCESS WILL ALLOW
STAKEHOLDERS. TO PROVIDE
THOUGHTFUL ANALYSES TO.
IMPLEMENT- IF THIRTEEN AND IT
THE BILL ASKED TDP TO LOOK AT
INTERNATIONAL HIGH RISK
FRAMEWORKS IN DEVELOPING THESE
REGULATIONS WHICH CAN INCLUDE
E. U. RUSE. THAT CLEARLY LIST
WHAT IS CONSIDERED HIGH RISK
ARE THE RHYTHMS. HI RICH
EXAMPLES INCLUDE ASSISTANCE AT
A SALVAGE PRIORITY INTO
DISPATCHING OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND CRIME PREDICTING
ALGORITHMS JUST TO NAME A FEW.
IT ALSO PROVIDES INDUSTRY WITH
HARMONIZED STANDARDS SOMETIMES
IT IS ALWAYS. UP LOOKING AND
ASKING FOR THE MORE WE HAVE
ASKED THE OPPOSITION TO
PROVIDE. THEIR PREFERRED
DEFINITION OF CHANGES THAT AND
WE HAVE NOT RECEIVED ANY TODAY.
DESPITE THIS WE ADDED THESE
EXCEPTIONS IN RESPONSE TO THEIR
CONCERNS AND REMAIN OPEN TO ANY
SUGGESTIONS. INDUSTRY HOUSE IN
CLARIFYING ANY OF THE TERMS OF
FINES AND BIGGIE WAS TO BE GO
ON TO STATE THAT A. B. THIRTEEN
INCREASES BERIA TO BID. FOR
GOVERNMENT CONTRACTS AND RISK
EXCLUDING SMALL BUSINESSES FROM
THE PROCESS OF FACT IS ALL
BUSINESSES MAKING BIT. HAVE
ACCESS TO THE DATA REQUIRED IN
THE IMPACT ASSESSMENT. THE
INFORMATION SOUGHT ONLY
REQUIRES THE BUSINESS TO
DESCRIBE THEIR POLICIES AND
THINK THROUGH THE IMPACTS OF
THEIR SYSTEMS AS A WAY. TO HELP
THE GOVERNMENT AGENCIES TO MAKE
BETTER INFORMED DECISIONS AND
DOES NOT PRESENT A HIGH BARRIER
TO ENTRY. DISTORTION THAT WE-
ADAPT WE REQUIRE BUSINESSES TO
AUDIT THEMSELVES AND DO NOT
PROTECT PROPRIETARY AND TRADE
SECRET INFORMATION IS ALSO
INACCURATE. THE ASSESSMENT ONLY
I ASKED BUSINESSES WHETHER THEY
HAVE CONDUCTED ANY AUDIT SO A
TASK ON THEIR HIGHWAY SYSTEM.
BUT IT'S NOT MANDATED TESTING
AND THE BILL SPECIFICALLY
STATES THAT COMPANIES DO NOT
HAVE TO DISCLOSE TREES SUCH
STATE TRADE SECRETS. IN THE END
IF THE UNDERLYING ASSERTION IS
THAT WE ARE PLACING ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR INDUSTRY TO
APPLY FOR CONTRACTS. THEN YOU
REMIND EVERYONE THAT THE
PURPOSE OF THE PROCUREMENT
PROCESS TO IS TO EVALUATE THE
SUITABILITY OF THE PRODUCTS OR
SERVICES OFFERED BY PROSPECTIVE
CONTRACTORS. FOR THE- TASK AT
HAND THE UNRUH CIVIL RIGHTS ACT
AS SOLID ESTABLISHES THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS. ARE FREE AND
EQUAL REGARDLESS OF. SPECIFIED
TOWARDS. SO ANY TO IN. AND A
MAN THAT'S THAT QUALITY IS BY
DEFINITION NOT SUITABLE FOR ANY
TYPE. CARRIED OUT BY THE STATE
NOR DOES IT NEED STANDARDS
DISTASTE SHOULD HOLD FOR THE-
USE OF TAXPAYERS MONEY FINALLY
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE STILL
CONCERNED ABOUT THE BILL WILL
DRIVE UP THE COST OF GOVERNMENT
WHICH I EXPLAINED EARLIER. HOW
FROM A VALUE STANDPOINT IT
COULD AND SHOULD BE ARGUED THAT
THE COST TO COMMUNITIES THIS
ADVANTAGE. BY DISCRIMINATORY
TECHNOLOGY FAR OUTWEIGHS THE
ADDITIONAL COST TO THE STATE.
SO WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMAN. THE MOTION BY
SENATOR GLACIER IS BEFORE US
THIS BILL WOULD BE MOVED AS
AMENDED THEN TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. SECTOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. DOT
NELSON NO NO SIR NO ALLEN ALL
RIGHT ALAN ARCHULETA BECKER.
FORGES BRADFORD LATER HI PLEASE
R. I. WESO. JONES CAN LONGER
MELENDEZ. ACCORDING TO YOU KNOW
I'VE PUT INTO YOU KNOW ALL
RIGHT RUBIO WELL. THREE ONE
SHERMAN ON CALL THREE ONE WE
WILL MOVE THE CALL THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. IF. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NOW TO ITEM NUMBER.
THREE EIGHTY FORTY SIX DO WE
HAVE A FAMILY MEMBER REVERSE
HERE THERE WE ARE. WELCOME
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REMISSION THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- I WANT TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR THOROUGH
EVALUATION OF THIS BILL AND BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS. I'M EXCITED TO
PRESENT A B. FORTY SIX A
CRITICAL YOUTH LED MEASURE
SEEKING TO ENSURE THAT STATE
LAWMAKERS HEAR THE VOICES OF
CALIFORNIA'S YOU. A. B. FORTY
SIX WILL ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH EMPOWERMENT
COMMISSION WHICH WILL BE
COMPROMISED SOLELY ABUSE AND
FOCUS ON POLICY ISSUES THAT
IMPACT YOUNG CALIFORNIANS. WELL
THERE ARE MULTIPLE COMMISSIONS
ADVISING THE STATE ON MATTERS
PERTAINING TO SPECIFIC
COMMUNITIES THERE IS NO
COMMISSION FOCUSED SPECIFICALLY
ON THE NEEDS OF YOU. AB FORTY
SIX WILL ADDRESS THIS LACK OF
REPRESENTATION BY ESTABLISHING
THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
EMPOWERMENT COMMISSION. THE
COMMISSION'S DUTIES WILL
INCLUDE EXAMINING POLICY
HOLDING MEETINGS WITH YOUTH
ADVOCATES. AND INVESTING IN
CRITICAL YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED
BY A WIDE COALITION OF YOUTH
ADVOCATES HOWEVER TO BE
RESPECTFUL OF THE COMMITTEE'S
TIME WE WILL NOT HAVE THEM
PROVIDE TESTIMONY TODAY. A. DO
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE NO
WITNESSES THAT ARE REGISTERED
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY OCCURRED
DURING THIS. MAN THAT SAID HEY
LET'S SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE IN
THE GALLERY WISHING TO TESTIFY.
FOR THE BILL. AND DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE. ONE
TWELVE APPARENTLY NOT. THAT
SAID. DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION.
WITNESSES MODERATOR COULD YOU
CHECK ON THE LINE FOR ANY
OPPOSITION. TO OPPOSITION FOR-
AB FORTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THE ONE
OPPOSITION ONLY AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR YES. OKAY ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO POINT TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND THEY
TOOK HIMSELF OUT TO KILL A LINE
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
TWELVE YOUR OPEN. FIND TWELVE
CAN YOU HEAR. WILL MOVE ON TO
LINE FORTY TWO. HI THIS IS
REBECCA GONZALEZ I THINK PEOPLE
ARE TAKING THEMSELVES OUT OF
QUEUE BECAUSE THEY NEVER CALLED
SUPPORT FOR CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF THE FELLOW NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER. YES I'M
GOING TO GET YOU WILL GET BACK
TO IT I APOLOGIZE I DID NOT
CALL FOR THE SURVEY ONLINE SO
GO AHEAD AND PROCEED. LET'S
STAY WITH THE SUPPORT FOR NOW
ARE THERE ANY OTHER SUPPORT
WITNESSES. IN Q. OKAY LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL AB
FORTY SIX GO AHEAD YEP ONE ZERO
NOW. AND WE WILL GO UP BY FORTY
TWO DID YOU WANNA STATE YOUR
SUPPORT OF YOUR DEBT. YES I
ALREADY GET THAT NATIONAL
IDENTIFICATION OF THOSE WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWENTY TWO. AMERICAN RECORD FOR
THAT IN CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR YOUTH MONIKER ON THIRD INTO
PART. NINE TWENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NICOLE MORTAL
MEN ON BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT. BY
TWENTY ONE. YOU ARE AVAILABLE.
HI GOOD MORNING TERROR MEMBERS
THIS IS LESLIE WITH THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS AND STRONG
SUPPORT. AND AGAIN IT'S A FINAL
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR-
AB FORTY SIX GO AHEAD. ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ALKALINE. TWELVE ALL OF THE
RECORDS F THE COUNTY LAW FOR
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. AND ONE MOMENT MISTER
CHAIR WE DO THAT ONE MORE
QUEUING UP. AND LINE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I
SUPPORT. SURE THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME OKAY WHO GO BACK TO
THEM MODERATOR TO ANY
ADDITIONAL THOSE REQUESTING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR OPPOSITION
TO AB. FORTY SIX. MR SURE
NOBODY IS KILLING US. OKAY THAT
SAID. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
REMEMBER. SENATOR BACKER
RESERVING DISABILITY GREAT IDEA
TO ENGAGE HIS YOUTH AND
HOPEFULLY WILL HELP DRIVE LOTS
OF POSITIVE POLICY OUTCOMES IN
THE FUTURE ON MOVE THE BILL
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE IT WOULD
BE APPROPRIATE NOW CENTER TO
BACK UP AND MOVE THE BILL BILL
IS MOVED THAT CHECK WOULD YOU
LIKE TO GIVE US A CLOSE FAMILY
MEMBER THANK YOU SENATORS FOR
CONSIDERING THIS IMPORTANT
PROPOSAL- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR ND I VOTE. VERY GOOD MR
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS FOLLOWED IN
THREE EIGHTY FORTY SIX MOTION
IS TO PASS THE- TO HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE DAUGHTER.
MILTON I NIELSEN HI ALAN. ALLEN
I ARCHULETA BECKER I BAKER HI
FORGES HALFORD GLAZER GLASER
ALRIGHT WESO JONES CAN LONGER
MELENDEZ POURED INTO YOU KNOW
HI TWENTY NO HI RUBIO WILL.
THAT'S FIVE FIVE CHAIRMAN ON
CALL WE WILL PLACE THE CALL
THANK YOU MEMBER THANK YOU.
EIGHT DO WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL. AND YOU HAVE A
B. SIXTY ONE SIR YES SIR PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
PERSON I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL ATTENTION
TO THEIR BILL AND THERE WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY. A SMALL
RESTAURANTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
STRUGGLE TO SURVIVE IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO FACILITATE EXPANDED
OUTDOOR DINING FOOD PREPARATION
AND SERVICE OPTIONS AND THIS
BILL WOULD EMPOWER LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOL AND
BEVERAGE CONTROL TO PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED REGULATORY RELIEF
TO SUPPORT STRUGGLING
RESTAURANTS ACROSS THE GOLDEN
STATE. NEIGHBORHOOD RESTAURANTS
ARE THE BACKBONE OF COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA BUT TOO MANY
ARE BARELY HANGING ON BY A
THREAD. OUTDOOR DINING OFFERS A
LIFELINE IN EXCITING ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY BY TAKING COURAGE
IN RESTAURANTS TO RE DISCOVER
NEW USES FOR THEIR OWN SPACE.
AS WE CONTINUE RE OPENING
OUTDOOR DINING IS LIKELY TO BE
CRITICAL IN THE NEAR FUTURE AND
A. B. SIXTY ONE ENTERS THE
CALIFORNIA FULLY SUPPORTS OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES. WE'RE PROUD
TO PARTNER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION ON THIS
EFFORT AND WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IS NOT SIGNED THE SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AT
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY. AND ARE BOTH.
VERY GOOD. WE HAVE A SUPPORT
WITNESSES WOULD YOU PLEASE
PROCEED. MODERATOR. YOUR LINE
SHOULD BE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORE IMAGES YOUR NUMBERS IT'S
NOT CERTAIN CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION- WE ARE
IN SUPPORT AND SPONSOR OF AB
SIXTY ONE. WE THINK WILL BE
SIXTY ONE THE TAKE SOME OF THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL ELEMENTS OF THE
PANDEMIC RELIEF FOR RESTAURANTS
AND EXTEND THOSE PROVISIONS AND
STATEWIDE RESTAURANT COMMUNITY
JUST GOT AUTHORIZED FULLY RE
OPENED ONE WEEK AGO TODAY.
THAT'S AFTER ONE YEAR OF COURSE
CLOSURES FOR POOL RESTAURANT
OPERATIONS SO AB SIXTY ONE
CONTINUES TO PLAY A CRITICAL
ROLE. EARLY IN THE PANDEMIC-
SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY. ABC IN
THE ADMINISTRATION ALLOWED A
STREAMLINED PROCESS FOR
RESTAURANT EXPAND THEIR OUTDOOR
DINING PUT PRINCE. ALCOHOL
SERVICE UNDER LOCATIONS NEAR OR
ADJACENT TO RESTAURANT PROPERTY.
IT IS BECAUSE OF THE TEMPORARY
CATERING AUTHORIZATION PERMIT.
THIS FLEXIBILITY ALLOWS
COMMUNITIES AFTER COMMUNITY TO
SET UP AN INNOVATIVE NEW RE
IMAGINED OUT OR DINING SPACES
THAT MANY OF YOU HAVE SEEN
THROUGHOUT YOUR DISTRICTS. FOR
THESE LOCAL PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
WIDELY SUCCESSFUL. TRANSFORMING
COMMUNITIES ADDING VIBRANCY IN
HELPING RESTAURANTS CONTINUE TO
OPERATE AND EXPAND THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO CAN ACTUALLY
INCLUDING AS OUR FOOTPRINT IT'S
ABLE TO BE EXPANDED. ENDED
OUTDOOR DINING WILL REMAIN A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THE
RESTAURANT RECOVERY AS
CONSTITUENTS AND CONSUMERS WILL
CONTINUE TO PRIORITIZE THAT
OUTDOOR DINING. TO THE
CONCERNED THIRTEEN INDOOR WORLD
MAYBE SIXTY ONE EXTENDS THE
WHAT IS BASICALLY BEEN A PILOT
PROJECT FOR THE LAST YEAR A
SUCCESSFUL PILOT PROJECT THAT
ALLOWS IT TO STICK AROUND WITH
TIGHT PUBLIC SAFETY CONTROLS
EACH OF THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
PANDEMIC EMERGENCY. SO YOU
THINK ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL
YOU SHERMAN DODGE- ACTING
CHAIRMAN NIELSEN AND SENATORS
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR VOTE- IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL TODAY THANK
YOU. TECHNICIAN CERTAIN.
MODERATOR DO HAVE ANYONE ELSE
IN Q. WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. ARE YOU REFERRING TO
THE PHONE LINES WHICH APPEAR
THAT I AM. OKAY THANK YOU
LATEST JUMP ON THE PHONE LINES
IF YOU'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE WILL
GO TO NINE ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FINAL EVER YOU ARE OPEN
PLEASE ON YOU. FINAL EVENT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WILL MOVE
ALONG THE LINE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE POLICE SHOT ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND LYING SIXTY YEAR YOU
ARE OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARTHA
GUERRERO REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORTING YOUR
IDOL THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WAITED ON
ME IN THE MORNING. HAMLINE
FORTY FOUR YOUR. MORNING MY
NAME IS ADDING UP AT THEY WOULD
END UP IN A HOSPITALITY
COOLIDGE REPRESENTING ELEVEN
ABOUT DROPPING SOMETHING
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
FINE ELEVEN AND THIRTY BUT HEALSO ADMITS STAR ONE TO SHOW
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
ELEVEN YEAR OLD. GOOD MORNING
JASON BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DOWNTOWN ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE BUSINESS
IMPROVEMENT DISTRICT OF KOREA
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU AND THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS CUED UP YOU
NOW KNOW WHAT NOT ANOTHER OKAY.
THE END OF OUR CENTER ARCHULETA
DID YOU HAVE SOMETHING ON THIS.
WHEN YOU'RE READY OKAY- BUT
LET'S. LET'S PROCEED THEN WITH
THE OPPOSITION AND THEN WOULD
BE BACK TO THE FLOOR HERE AND
SENATOR ARCHULETA WOULD BE NEXT
DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION.
TESTIMONY MODERATOR WE REQUEST
THAT OPPOSITION TESTIMONY IF
ANY IS THERE. THANK YOU HI
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO AB SIXTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND AGAIN
TO SHOW OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE
WILL ALIGN FIFTY SIX. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MICHAEL SKIP ON
BEHALF OF ALCOHOL JUSTICE. WHAT
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL. WE
ARE IN FAVOR OF PUBLIC HEALTH
NOT PUBLIC DRINKING THANK YOU
FOR. AND THE FINAL REMINDER TO
SHOW OPPOSITION- AB SIXTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. WE HAVE NOBODY ELSE
QUEUED UP. OKAY AND DO WE HAVE
ANY IN THE GALLERY. WISHES TO
TESTIFY. AND DO WE HAVE ANY.
AND ONE TWELVE CURRENTLY NOT.
THAT SAID WE'RE BACK TO THE
FLOOR AND SENATOR ARCHULETA I
BELIEVE THAT YOU WISH TO ASK A
QUESTION OR COMMENT. HERE IT'S
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE AUTHOR
FOR HIS FINE WORK ON THIS BILL-
IT IS ABOUT TIME THAT WE HELP
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY. AND
THESE RESTAURANTS HAVE BEEN
HURT- MONTH AFTER MONTH I THINK
NOW WE CAN ALL ENJOY A NICE DAY
EVENING- AT A RESTAURANT. IN WE
NEED TO HELP THEM AND THIS IS A
GREAT BILL TO START THAT AND
MOVE US FORWARD AS WE OPEN THE
ECONOMY WE HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE SUFFERING THAT THEY'VE HAD
THE NUMBER OF MONTHS THAT
THEY'VE- LOST REVENUES AND
EMPLOYEES AND NOW EVERYONE'S
COMING BACK. SO WE ENCOURAGE-
THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY PLEASE
CONTINUE TO OPEN DOORS AND-
GIVE US A SERVICE THAT WE ALL
REMEMBER. SO WITH THAT I URGE I
WROTE AND I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE
THE BILL AT APPROPRIATE TIME.
THEY HAVE SOMEONE IN THE
GALLERY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TESTIFY. I HAVE I APOLOGIZE
MISTER CHAIR FOR BEING TARDY
CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF
THE HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. VERY
GOOD WE'VE GOT THAT COVERED
THAT- GENDER BECKER. I'LL JUST
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE IN THE FORTIES
SUPPORTING THE BILL. VERY GOOD.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WISHING TO CON THAT.
OR AK QUESTIONS HAPPY TO MOVE
THE BILL MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE THE GENDER ARE CHILLIN I
BELIEVE IS MOVED THE BILL. DO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GIVE US A
CLOSE. YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHERRY JUST WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR KIND
COMMENTS AND I AGREE- YOU KNOW
WE THE SMALL RESTAURANTS ARE
THE BACKBONE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. THANKFULLY MY WIFE
AND I ARE VACCINATED BUT WE
HAVE THREE SMALL CHILDREN WHO
ARE UNVACCINATED AND SO OUTDOOR
DINING IS GOING TO BE PART OF
OUR GAME PLAN. FOR THE SORT
FORESEEABLE FUTURE AND SO ALL
OF THE REGULATORY FLEXIBILITY
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE TO THESE
RESTAURANTS WILL BE VERY
MEANINGFUL TO THEM TO OUR LOCAL
ECONOMIES INTO OUR STATE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMAN GABRIEL
AND MR SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FOLLOWED HIM FOR A. B. C. ONE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
HELP COMMITTEE DOT NIELSEN ALL
RIGHT NIELSEN HI ALAN HI ALAN I
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA ICEBREAKER
BY BAKER HI FORGES BRADFORD
GLAZER HI PLEASE R. IGHT WESO
JONES CAN LONGER MELENDEZ
ACCORDING TO YOU KNOW HI
ACCORDING TO YOU KNOW. I RUBIO
WELL. S. GERMAN I'M- THE PLACE
THE CALL CENTER MEMBER AND THIS
BILL. BILL AS AMENDED TO THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE NOW WILL MOVE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB FOUR
TWELVE. ASSEMBLYMEMBER RANCH.
WELCOME. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. I WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING ACCEPTING THE
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS IN THE
ANALYSIS AND I THANK THE CHAIR
AND THE COMMITTEE. FOR WORKING
WITH MY TEAM ON THIS ISSUE. SO
TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU AB FOR
TWELVE WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH
THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
HUMAN RIGHTS ADVISORY BOARD
TASKED WITH REVIEWING THE
STATUS OF HUMAN RIGHTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THE PROTECTION AND
ADVANCEMENT OF HUMAN RIGHTS IS
A CORNERSTONE OF GOVERNMENT.
ALTHOUGH OTHER AGENCIES
RESPONSIBLE FOR REVIEWING
ISSUES MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES
FACE THERE IS NO CENTRALIZED
ORGANIZATION THAT LOOKS AT THE
OVER ARCHING HUMAN RIGHTS
ISSUES. EIGHTY FOUR TWELVE
COULD CREATE A FORMAL TATE
ENTITY THAT IDENTIFIES HUMAN
RIGHTS ABUSES CONCERNS FOR
SHORT OR SHORT COMINGS
INCLUSIVE OF THE INTERSECTION
OF VARIOUS FORMS OF
DISCRIMINATION. CONSIDERING THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT THE
PANDEMIC HAS HAD ON
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES THE
NEED TO ENSURE RECOVERY IS DONE
IN AN EQUITABLE MANNER AND THAT
MOVING FORWARD THE HUMAN RIGHTS
OF ALL ARE PROTECTED IS OF
UTMOST IMPORTANCE. EIGHTY FOUR
TWELVE WOULD CENTRALIZE THE
CONVERSATION ON HUMAN RIGHTS
AND BRING TOGETHER LEADERS
EXPERTS AND LEGISLATORS TO
EXAMINE THE STATUS OF HUMAN
RIGHTS. AND PRODUCE REGULAR
REPORTS THAT CAN BE UTILIZED TO
GUIDE POLCY. HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS AMBER SHEET FROM
CARE CALIFORNIA AND JOSEPH
SUAREZ SUAREZ. FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO COMMISSION ON HUMAN
RIGHTS. OKAY THANK YOU SHIRLEY
MEMBER AND YOUR FIRST WITNESS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROCEED THEN
AND YOUR SUPPORT TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU SCHERING CENTER THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME HERE
TODAY MY NAME IS AMBER SHE'S
REPRESENTING CARE CALIFORNIA
THE LARGEST MUSLIM RIGHTS
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION IN THE
COUNTRY AND WE ARE PROUD TO BE
CO SPONSORS OF THIS BILL
ALONGSIDE CHERYL- AND THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. WE ALSO THINK IT'S ON
THE MEMBER IS FOR HER
LEADERSHIP. AND HUMAN RIGHTS
OFFERING THE BILL. IN AN AGE IN
WHICH ARE SOCIETY IS SEEN
INCREASE HATE. AN ARRAY OF
COMMUNITIES RENEWING
CONVERSATION DROPS STOMACH
BARRIERS. AND IDENTIFYING AN
ARRAY OF COMMUNITY AT THE END
AND IN MANY CASES CONTINUE TO
BE FOR KARNATAKA CRACKS. MAKING
A REPORT. ALL OF THIS MAKES
EIGHTY FOUR TWELVE TIMELINESS
SUBSIDY WHICH PROVIDES A
MECHANISM FOR IMPERATIVE HUMAN
RIGHTS CENTER CONVERSATIONS.
AND POLICIES WHICH- TOO MANY.
CONTINUE TO FALL THE CRACKS OF
BLACK REPRESENTATION OF POLICY
CONSIDERATIONS OFTEN DEALING
WITH THE HARSH UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT THEME PARK
CONSTRUCTION AND
IMPLEMENTATION. AND THERE'S NO
ENTITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHOSE SOLE TASK IS
TO REVIEW THE RIGHT THE
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS SECTORS AND
JUST- IN ORDER TO ADEQUATELY
MITIGATE GOODNESS WHEN THAT.
EIGHTY FOUR TWELVE WOULD
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITY FOR
INCREASED PARTNERSHIP AND
DIALOGUE ACROSS THE STAGE AND
SERVE AS A KEY ADVISORY ROLE IN
IDENTIFYING THESE JOBS. AND
HUMAN RIGHTS CENTEED SOLUTIONS
FOR MOST OF THE MARGINALIZED IN
CALIFORNIA. SERVING AS AN
ENTITY WHICH WOULD BE MADE UP
OF HUMAN RIGHTS XPERTS FROM
CALIFORNIA DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
THE COMMISSION ON HUMAN RIGHTS
CAN CONNECT ACROSS SECTORS AND
SYSTEM CALIFORNIA TO IDENTIFY
AND TACKLE LARGER. SCALE SYSTEM
WIDE ISSUES WHICH IMPEDE ON THE
RIGHTS OF ALL CALIFORNIANS. IT
IS IMPERATIVE THAT AN ENTITY IN
CALIFORNIA TALKING HUMAN RIGHT
TO THE LAND AND MANDATES THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN CONTINUE TO LOOK
TO PROTECT. ITS BEAUTIFULLY
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES AND LEAD
THE NATION IN THE PROTECTION
THE ELEVATION OF HUMAN RIGHTS.
IT IS WITH THE REASON THEY'RE
ACTUALLY- DRIVE OKAY THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
MR SHADE. DO WE HAVE ANY OF
WITNESS EVIDENCE. IN TWO.
PODERIA. SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR-
PHOEBE OR TWENTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY I
APOLOGIZE IT'S B. B. FOR TWELVE.
AND PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY A ZERO FOR A BFORE TWELVE
AND WE WILL BEGIN. WITH ONE
FORTY TWO. FIVE FORTY TWO IT
SOMEHOW YOU WANT OUT OF QUEUE
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AGAIN AND WE'LL GO TO SIXTY
SEVEN. THE MORE MATURE MEMBERS
CHRISTOPHER SPONSORS ARE W.
COLLECTION CENTER LAN PARTY.
PROBABLY COSPONSORS MOVED IN ON
THE RIVER. FLOW AND THERE'S
FORTY TWO. YOU ARE OPEN. GO
AHEAD PLEASE HELLO CAN I CAN
YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN'T FIND.
THIS IS JUST A SWIPE FIGHTER OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO HUMAN RIGHTS
COMMISSION I AM ONE OF THE-
WITNESS TESTIMONY TO THAT OKAY
I SPEAK NOW. OF COURSE. THANK
YOU CHAIR AND SENATORS FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY AND THANK YOU READER
RATES FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THE BILL MY NAME IS JOSEPH
SLICE ONCE AGAIN I'M THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
HUMAN RIGHTS COMMISSION I'LL BE
BRIEF THE COMMISSIONER I'VE
BEEN ABLE TO WITNESS FIRSTHAND
THE INCREDIBLE WORK THAT HUMAN
RIGHTS FOCUSED ENTITY CAN
ACHIEVE WITHIN GOVERNMENT BY
RESPONDING TO INEQUITY AND
DISCRIMINATION IN FACT DURING
THIS IS SPECIALLY DIFFICULT
YEAR OUR STATE PUBLIC HEALTH
SAFETY AND ECONOMY THE SAN
FRANCISCO HRC HAS BEEN AN
INVALUABLE PARTNER IN THE CITY.
STAFF WERE INTEGRAL TO THE
CITY'S CALLED THE COMMAND
CENTER INSURING THAT FAST
SHAPING POLICY THAT INFORMATION
WERE VIEWED WITH AN EQUITABLE
LAND THIS IS ONE OF THE REASONS
SAN FRANCISCO WITH A MODEL CITY
FOR THE REST OF THE NATION IN
COVERT RESPONSE AND FOR RECORD
BREAKING AN EQUITABLE VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION MAKING THIS ONE OF
THE HIGHEST VACCINATED
POPULATIONS. IN THE WORLD AND
NEARING HERD IMMUNITY. CITY
WIDE WORK FOR DEVELOP. GRANTS
AND FUNDING INITIATIVES FOR
FIVE O'CLOCK AN LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY. AND KEY REPORTING
MECHANISMS ARE JUST SOME OF THE
EXAMPLES OF THE HRC SCOPE THE
STATE. BEYOND ITS INVESTIGATORY
AND MEDIA TORY FUNCTION. IT'S
CRITICAL WORK WHILE INVALUABLE
AND EXHAUSTED IT'S NOT ENOUGH
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
CONVERSATION CENTERING HUMAN
RIGHTS AND HOW WE CONTINUE TO
UP WITH THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS IN OUR STATE. ARE
BECOMING INCREASINGLY COMPLEX
AND NECESSARY. EIGHTY FOUR
TWELVE WOULD PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR INCREASED
PARTNERSHIP AND DIALOGUE ACROSS
THE STATE. AND SERVE AS A KEY
ADVISORY ROLE TO THE STATE
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE SEE HOW COLD
IT. CLIMATE CHANGE AND OTHER
ISSUES DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT ARE VULNERABLE
POPULATION. JUST AS MEMBER
RADIANCE THAT. A STATEWIDE
ENTITY POPULATED BY EXPERTS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO TARGET
THESE ISSUES AS THEY ARISE WILL
BENEFIT ALL RESIDENTS AND
BUSINESSES. THE SAN FRANCISCO
HUMAN RIGHTS COMMISSION IS
ALREADY IN COLLABORATION WITH
SISTER AGENCIES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA NEW YORK AND BEYOND.
BUT WITH THE STATE BODY THIS
WORK THE PARTNERSHIPS AND
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTISE WOULD
ONLY STRENGTHEN AND BETTER
SERVE OUR LEGISLATURE LOCALLY
AND NATIONALLY. THAT'S WHY THE
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO THROUGH
THE STATE LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE
HAS FORMALLY APPROVED THE
SUPPORT EIGHTY FOUR TWELVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
IT WAS AN HONOR TO CALL. IN AND
I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
EYEBALLS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THERE ARE NO WITNESSES IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE WHICH TESTIFY- WILL
NOT NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR THIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE PROPPED
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOR TWELVE.
THANK YOU RICHER- AGAIN PRESS
ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT FOR- A
BEFORE TWELVE AT THIS TIME.
PRESS ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT FOR
AV ONE TWELVE AND- FOR TWELVE
WE'LL BEGIN WITH ONE FORTY TWO.
REBECA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
AND THE FINAL REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR A. B. FOR
TWELVE. MISTER CHAIR NOBODY
ELSE'S QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MODERATOR HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPPORTERS
WILL NOW FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY
SEEING NONE. THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES IN ROOM FOUR TWELVE.
AND NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE URBIS
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION TO AB
FOR TWELVE. THANK YOU.
EXPRESSED OPPOSITION FOR AB FOR
TWELVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
AND WE WILL GO TO ONE THIRTY
FIVE. ALL MORNING SCOTT WITH
PLASTER COUNTY IN. AND AGAIN TO
SHOW OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS.
ZERO. MR TRUMP MR SURE NOBODY
ELSE WAS QUEUING UP. THANK YOU
MODERATOR- THANKS TO ALL OUR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WILL NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO THE MEMBERS TO ANY
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING THAT SUCCESS-
BACKER. VERY MUCH SUPPORT THIS
THIS BILL THIS IDEA NOW MOVE IT
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I
WOULD CONSIDER THAT A MOTION
THIS- MOVED IN THE OTHER
COMMENTS- WITH THAT- THIS
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
ALTHOUGH- ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. OKAY THIS SECTOR CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL YES
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVEN A. B.
FOUR ONE TWO TWO OUR MOTION IS
TO PASS AMENDED TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE DOT. DOT HI NELSON
WELL YES AND NO ALAN. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA I'D- BY
BECKER I FORGES. BRADFORD
GLAZER HI LATER I WAS SO JOHNS
NO. JONES NO CAN LONGER
MELENDEZ FOURTEEN TO NO HI
TWENTY NO I'M RUBIO SAYS WILL.
AT SIX FIFTY GERMAN ENCORE AT
SIX SITES TO THOSE WILL PLACES
BILL- PAUL WILL NOW MOVE TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT. A. B.
NINE FIFTEEN THE SEVEN MEMBER
CHEW YOU ARE YOU HERE. CSMA
MEMBER.
TO MORNING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO IF YOU'REREADY YOU
MAY BEGIN SIR GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR COLLEAGUES MAYBE
NINE FIFTEEN WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA LIVE UP TO ITS
PROMISE TO SUPPORT SMALL
DIVERSE BUSINESSES PARTICULARLY
TO COME OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC IN
RECESSION. IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER SIGNED
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER ESTABLISHING
A GOAL FOR ALL STATE AGENCIES.
THAT 25% OF CONTRACTS SHOULD GO
TO SMALL BUSINESSES. SINCE THEN
AGENCIES HAVE LARGELY IGNORED
THAT ORDER. ONLY TWELVE OF TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE STATE
AGENCIES DEPARTMENTS AND
COMMISSIONS. HAVE ADOPTED A
RELEVANT POLICY. GIVEN THE
ENORMOUS PURCHASING POWER OF
THE STATE AN ENORMOUS HIT SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE TAKEN DURING
THE PANDEMIC WE SQUANDER REAL
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP THESE
BUSINESSES RECOVER. THIS BILL
WOULD CODIFY THAT 25% GOING TO
LAW. CREATE A FAST TRACK
CERTIFICATION FOR DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESS ENTERPRISES. AND
CREATE ECONOMIC EQUITY FIRST
POLICIES TO REQUIRE STATE
AGENCIES TO DEVELOP PLANS FOR
PROCURING GOODS FROM DVDS. WITH
THAT- WILL TURN OVER TO WIN
THIS. OKAY NOW WILL- MOVE TO
ANYONE- WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FAMILY MEMBER TO I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE DAVID NELSON
HERE IN THE GALLERY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING. IT'S
A SHERIN SENATORS MY NAME IS
DAVID NELSON AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC POLICY FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. AND ITS
HARVESTING PRIVILEGE TO BE CO
SPONSORING THIS LEGISLATION
WITH THE CALIFORNIA AFRICAN
AMERICAN IN CALIFORNIA HISPANIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. BEYOND
THAT THOUGH IT TRULY IS AN
HONOR TO BE STANDING HERE TODAY
KAREN THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO ON
BEHALF OF THE FOUR MILLION
SMALL BUSINESSES. THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TO REMAIN OPEN RIGHT
NOW IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
41% OF WHICH STILL REMAIN CLOSE
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF OUR
PANDEMIC. YOUR YOUR SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS AND MINORITY
BUSINESS OWNERS ARE TOLD THAT
THEY ARE THE BACKBONE OF OUR
ECONOMY AND THE FIFTH FLOOR OF
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD. GET YOUR EVERY YEAR
THESE BUSINESSES ARE TREATED AS
IF THE SAFETY AND SECURITY THAT
LARGE BUSINESSES AND
CORPORATIONS CAN AFFORD ALSO
EXIST FOR THEM. THE TRUTH IS.
THEY DON'T N. A. B. NINE ONE
FIVE IS A PIECE OF LEGISLATION
WHOSE TIME HAS COME. IT WILL
DELIVER ACCOUNTABILITY AND
EQUITY WHEN IT COMES TO STATE
CONTRACTING AND PROCUREMENT.
SINCE 2000625% PROCUREMENT TO
SMALL BUSINESSES HAS EXISTED AS
A GOAL BUT ULTIMATELY AN
UNACCOUNTABLE AND UNENFORCEABLE
ONE. EIGHTY NINE ONE FIVE
ESTABLISHES THE NECESSARY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND FRAMEWORK.
TO MAKE THIS GOAL A REALITY FOR
THOUSANDS OF SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT ARE OPEN RIGHT NOW. SMALL
BUSINESSES TRULY ARE THE
BEDROCK OF OUR ECONOMY. THEY
CONTINUE TO DELIVER TO THE
SUCCESS OF OUR OVERALL ECONOMY.
AND I WOULD PROPOSE TO YOU THAT
THERE IS NO GREATER BENCHMARK
OF SUCCESS FOR A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER. THEN MAKING PAYROLL.
HIRING A NEIGHBOR AND FEEDING
THEIR CHILDREN. THAT IS WHY I
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. YOUR
IPHONE ON A. B. NINE ONE FIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SEE NOBODY
ELSE IN THE GALLERY AND NOBODY
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE I WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESS WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
E. B. NINE ONE FIVE. THANK YOU
L. EDITION SUPPORT FOR A. B.
NINE FIFTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME FOR AN
OPERATOR CAN GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER OFFLINE. AND WE'LL BEGIN
WITH WINE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT IS ADAM KAPLAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION
WHERE COURT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NINE SEVENTY FOUR YOU ARE
ALL SET. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN VERSION RUNNING CAN BE
A LITTLE SCREWS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FORD ACTION FUND
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE ANALYST CONNIE CHAN ON
BEHALF OF STATE TREASURER FIONA
MODELS IN SUPPORT AT EIGHTY
NINE FIFTEEN THANK YOU. THE
FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A. B.
NINE FIFTEEN AT ONE SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MANY DHEA
PICKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SPENDING. COMMERCE
PRODUCT WAS FOUNDER OF THE BILL
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT. SURE
THERE ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU- HAVING HER FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY
SCENE DONE. IN I SEE NONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO NINE
ONE FIVE NOW WE'LL MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE RIVERS
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION TO THE
SP NINE ONE FIVE. THANK YOU.
AGAIN TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO NINE EIGHTEEN NINE ONE FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP MISTER
CHAIR. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL NOW BRING THIS
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE MEMBERS.
SENATOR ARCHULETA THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
YOUNG THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD IN HIS CHAIR OF
THE MILITARY VETERANS COMMITTEE
I'M ESPECIALLY PROUD TO SEE
THAT DISABLED VETERANS BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE IS INCLUDED AND I
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL AT
THE TIME THANK YOU CENTER
ARCHULETA THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED
SENATOR GLAZER. THERE ARE THERE
ARE TIMES WITH BILLS THAT COME
BEFORE US AND WE SAY. YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT IS THIS DOING HERE
AND THERE TO BILLS THAT COME
BEFORE US WE SAY WHY DID IT
TAKE SO LONG. AND I'D SAY THIS
IS THE CERTAINLY THE CATEGORY
FOR THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
WHAT IS IT TAKING SO LONG AND
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR. AND
HIS CO AUTHOR FOR THEIR WORK IN
THE SYRIAN HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO-
CALL CENTER ARCH ALETTA. SORRY
MR I WOULD LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND
SAY I WOULD BE PROUD TO BE A
CULTURE AS WELL. CO AUTHOR I'M
SORRY. OKAY SO THIS BILL'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR ARCHULETA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE SECTOR
BUT- THE SENTIMENT YOU I'M
SORRY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSER
AGAIN RESPECTFULLY- AFTER
SUPPORTING APPRECIATE THAT THE
SUPPORT THAT HAS BEEN INDICATED
BY SOME SENATORS HERE TODAY
THANK YOU SEVEN MEMBER. I MISS
SECTOR WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
DOT HI DONNA HI NIELSEN HI YES
AND I ALAN ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA
I'D. BACKER BOARD YES. BRADFORD
GLAZER I PLEASE IGHT WESO.
JONES HI JONES HI KEN LONGER.
MELENDEZ PUT INTO YOU KNOW HI
FLORENTINO INES RUBIO. RUBIO I
WILL. SEVEN ZERO GERMAN UNCLE
THAT WAS SEVEN ZERO EIGHT.
SEVEN ZERO THAT DOES ALL CALL
THANK YOU SEMI MEMBER. WE'RE
LOOKING NOW FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA.
WE HAVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM
UP ON DECK. SEE IF WE CAN GET
SOMEBODY HERE PLEASE. AND IF
ANYBODY FROM THE FAMILY MEMBER
MARISSA- CHEESE OFFICES
WATCHING. YOU COULD SEND HIM
DOWN AS WELL. THE.
OKAY WILL
NOW MOVE TO FOLLOW THE NUMBER
TEN D. B. ELEVEN TWENTY SIX
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM YOU MAY
COLLEAGUES I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT A B. ELEVEN TWENTY SIX
WHICH WILL ESTABLISH THE
COMMISSION ON THE STATE OF HATE
I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WE'RE ALL AWARE OF
THE ALARMING INCREASE IN HATE
CRIMES AND TRAGICALLY THESE
CRIMES ARE BECOMING MORE
VIOLENT AND MORE DEADLY AND-
MORE COMMON. DO THE STAGGERING
STATISTICS AND CHALLENGES OF
MONITORING COLLECTING AND
ANALYZING DATA. IT'S CLEAR THAT
CALIFORNIA NEEDS BETTER TOOLS
AND DEDICATED INDIVIDUALS TO
HELP US TRACK AND REPORT THIS
INFORMATION. THE COMMISSION ON
THE STATE OF HATE WILL MONITOR
AND ASSESS CURRENT TRENDS
RELATIVE TO HATE CRIMES PRODUCE
ANNUAL REPORTS ON THESE TRENDS
AND MAKE POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS
TO THE LEGISLATURE GOVERNOR.
AND RELEVANT STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS IN ORDER TO HELP
THE STATE BE AWARE OF ADDRESS
AND HOPEFULLY REDUCE INSTANCES
OF THESE CRIMES. THE COMMISSION
IS NECESSARY IN ORDER TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND WHO IS PERPETRATING
THESE CRIMES WHO IS BEING
TARGETED. WHERE AND WHY THEY
ARE BEING TARGETED. AND HOW WE
CAN DEVELOP POLICY SOLUTIONS TO
ADDRESS AND REDUCE THE
INSTANCES OF THESE CRIMES AND
FINALLY WHAT THOSE NEW POLICIES
MIGHT LOOK LIKE I AM PLEASED TO
HAVE PROFESSOR BRIAN LEVIN
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER OF THE
CENTER FOR THE STUDY OF HATE
AND EXTREMISM AT CSU SAMBAR
DINO TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
BABY ELEVEN TWENTY SIX. THANK
YOU MISS LEVIN YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU CHAIRPERSON DADA MAY
I ADD A PROUD ALUMNI THE CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM- AND
THE REST OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME HERE.
YOU CAN EXTREME VALUE.
PERMANENT FACIAL TRANSPARENT
NONPARTISAN FACT FINDING
ENTITY. EIGHT PUBLIC POLICY IN
THIS NARROW. EXPERIENCE THE
AREA HIT MANY CALIFORNIANS.
THREE THREE ONE WHICH TO
INTERGROUP CONFLICT AND
VIOLENCE AND ESPECIALLY
REGARDING GLOBAL COMMUNITIES
BUT MOREOVER FOR MERGING TREND
ON VIOLENT THREATS TO OUR
PLURALISTIC DEMOCRACY ARGUES
THE CONFLATION BETWEEN
TRADITIONAL. HATE CRIMES AND
NOW. SURE WHO TRIED THE OTHER
GROUP VIOLENCE FOR INSTANCE
WE'RE SEEING AN INCREASING IN
THREATS AGAINST GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS IMAGINE. IT'S BEEN
STATED WE DON'T HOLD THE STOCK
READY APPROACH SPECIFICALLY
BECAUSE USUALLY MORE FLUID AND
RAPIDLY. RAPIDLY CHANGING. DID
YOU OF COURSE EAST. REACHES
INTO THE MAINSTREAM AND IT
INCLUDES SUCH. YOU HAD A
VANDALISM IN ORANGE COUNTY FOR
INSTANCE THE MATERIALS CAME
FROM THE EUROPEAN HATE GROUP
MOREOVER A DISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGN BY THE RUSSIANS
PARTICULARLY WITH REGARD TO
CALIFORNIA SECEDING. I'M GOING
ALL MR GARCIA. SO YOU'RE POINT
WHERE I'M ENTITY FOR YOUR SCALP
NETWORKS THAT STARTED ALL THE
WAY BACK WITH COMMISSIONS
JORDAN WOULD YOU TREAT
GENERAL'S OFFICE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT TRIGGERED
YOU BECAUSE PEOPLE LEAVE OFFICE
AND YOUR TERM LIMITS BUT WE
HAVE THE NGO HUMAN RELATIONS
GROUPS ACADEMIA AND COMMUNITY
FOLKS THAT CAN RESPOND TO THESE
RAPID CHANGES MOREOVER. THE
REGIONALIZATION OF EXTREMISM SO
WE'RE SEEING FOLKS TRAVEL
ACROSS REGIONS AND BECOME SELF
RADICALIZED ON THE INTERNET
YEAH WE HAVE A RIGHT TO BE HERE
IN THE STATE OF RADI OF
LEGISLATION IN ORDER TO TAKE
THE PLACE. IT MADE SUGGESTIONS.
MPD WHAT ENTER ALTHOUGH I
BECAUSE- PEOPLE ACTED EXPERTS
HELLO MAKERS AGREE. TO KEEP OF
WHAT IS GOING ON FINALLY
CREATURE RAPID BASIS BUT WITH
EXTREMISM IT IS NOW WE DON'T
WE'RE SEEING THE TRACKS WHEN
YOU OUT SO WE'RE WITH THE STATE
RESIDENTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THANKS TO THE BOTTOM LINE IS
NOW WHAT WE'RE SEEING HERE TO
DATE INCREASE IN HATE CRIMES
JUST SO FAR IN LOS ANGELES. 66%
OF YORK CITY A 117% I'M QUOTING
LOOKING AT VERIZON WE'VE BEEN
COUNTING IN ANTI SEMITIC CASES
JUST THIS MAY AN INVENTORY
USUALLY CARDS WHICH YOU ONLY
ACCELERATED FROM A HUNDRED AND
50% INCREASE LAST YEAR 210090%
INCREASE THIS YEAR. SO THE
ABILITY TO GET USED WIDE RANGE
OF EXPERTS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS AND PUT THEM INTO SUB
COMMITTEES THAT CAN HELP ADVISE
THE POLICY RESPONSE IS SO
IMPORTANT I WANT TO THANK YOU
FROM WE PERSON WON'T. OTHER
SUPPORTERS OF THIS WE NEED
INDEPENDENT NON PARTISAN
DIVERSIFIED. AND DATA DRIVEN
ENTITY. IT CAN HELP ADVISE
POLICY IN A WAR TIME WAY
BECAUSE THAT WHAT IT CAN HELP
THOSE. AND WE SEE MORE HAPPENED
FOR INSTANCE MY READ. IN NEW
YORK CITY WITH A FAILED OUR G.
WE SAW TO PUT YOUR COMMUNITY
WHEN WE KNEW FOR. PAST
IMPRIMATUR PASS DATA OF WE'RE
THE SHOULD DIP. BECAUSE OF AN
INCREASE IN CRIME AND THANK YOU
SO. HELLO IS NOW ON. AHA BED
FOR MANY OF THESE EXTREMISTS
AND THEY'RE GOING TO WELL NOT
ONLY ARE MORE TRADITIONAL TYPES
OF HATRED BETWEEN OUR COURT THE
LEGEND AND UNFORTUNATELY PUBLIC
OFFICIALS SCHOOL TEACHERS.
OTHERS OR BEING PUT INTO THIS.
RABBIT IS ALIVE AND WELL AT
LEAST WE COULD AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES RAPIDLY AND THAT'S
WHY WE NEED THIS ENTITY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE OF ADDRESSING THE
SENATE TODAY. THANK YOU. ARE
THERE- NO WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWELVE- WILL NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF. A B.
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX. BEGIN TO
SHOW SOME FOR A ELEVEN TWENTY
SO. PLEASE PRESS ONE FOR BY THE-
ONE FILED ZERO TO YOUR FOR A B.
ONE SO AND WE WILL BE. WITH
LINE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING TURNED
TWENTY MEMBERS TOMMY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT. WE'LL GO TO
LINE FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING REBECCA GONZALEZ
FOR THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ON LINE. FIFTY FOUR YOU ARE
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS JOHN HOSER
CHAIR AND CEO OF THESE REALLY
AMERICAN CIVIC ACTION NETWORK
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
A. B. ONE ONE TWO SIX YOUR-
FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A. B. ONE TWENTY
SIX. NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MODERATOR- THE HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPPORTERS
WILL NOT FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY
OPPOSED SEEING NONE. I ALSO SEE
NONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE THANK
YOU NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORDERS
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING. TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX. ALRIGHT. ONE THIRTY
FIVE YOUR AND FOR EVERYBODY
ELSE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY THE
ROAD BUT I POSITION. YEAH. GET
ANYBODY ELSE TO SHOW OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND NOBODY ELSE IS
QUEUING UP. THANK YOU WERE
GOING TO BRING THIS BACK TO-
OUR MEMBERS IN THE DISCUSSION.
WHAT IS SENATOR GLAZER. C.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I THINK
THAT ALL OF US HAVE BEEN
DISTURBED BY THE- PROLIFERATION
OF ACTS OF HATE IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND OUR STATE OUR
NATION- AND I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR MOVING THIS BILL TO
OUR ATTENTION AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORTED HAPPY TO MOVE IT AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. OKAY I
DON'T SEE ANY OTHER MIKES
RAISED- CENTRE ALAN SKEWS ME
YEAH I JUST WANT TO. ADD M
VOICE IN SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
AND I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP HE'S BEEN. A
LEADER IN THIS SPACE FOR QUITE
SOME TIME. INCLUDING WITH THE
SELECT COMMITTEE- IT IS
ABSOLUTELY ABHORRENT SOME OF
THE TRENDS THAT WE'RE SEEING-
FOR SO MANY COMMUNITIES AND IT
IS NOT THE- CALIFORNIA THAT I
KNOW AND LOVE. AND I JUST HOPE
THAT THIS BILL WILL HELP US.
GET TO A PLACE WHERE WE CAN WE
CAN- TRACKING UNDERSTAND THESE
DANGEROUS TRENDS AND MOVE US
BACK TOWARDS- A BELOVED
COMMUNITY. TO PARAPHRASE DR
KING SO THANK YOU I HAVE A
SUMMER BLOOM FOR BRAND IMPORT
THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL FORD.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN- THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
GLAZER THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
AS AMENDED TO JUDICIARY- COULD
WE- WOULD YOU LIKE TO- HAVE ANY
CLOSING REMARKS- SET A SEVEN
MEMBER WHO I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE SENATORS FOR THEIR KIND
REMARKS IN SUPPORT AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK DERIVE A- OKAY
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. DONNA HI DONNA HI
NIELSEN NO BILL SENT NO ALAN.
HI ALAN I OR TWO LATER HI OR TO
LET ICE BANKER. FORGES RADFORD
LASER EYE LASER EYE WESSEL.
WESSEL I JONES NO JONES NO CAN
LONGER MELENDEZ PUT INTO YOU
KNOW. TWENTY NO I RUBIO. WELL.
SIXTY TWO GERMAN S. SIX VOTES
TO AGAINST- WILL PLACE THE BILL
ON CALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. HE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MERCI CHE SI YOU
BACK THERE WILL MOVE TO FILE
ITEM- NUMBER ELEVEN AB.
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT. YOU MAY
BEGIN SIR THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
GOOD MORNING SENATORS I'M HERE
TO PRESENT ABC FIFTEEN THIRTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT. WE SAW DURING THE
PANDEMIC THAT- THERE WERE
TREMENDOUS DISPARITIES- IN
REGARDS TO THE CLUB IN
NINETEEN- VIRUS NOT ONLY ALONG
RACIAL LINES. BUT ALSO ALONG
ETHNIC LINES FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITIES. THERE WAS
TREMENDOUS DISPARITY WITH THE
HARDEST HIT. ASIAN ETHNIC
GROUPS INCLUDING THE FILIPINOS
VIETNAMESE AND- NATIVE
HAWAIIANS. SO THIS BILL SEEKS
TO REQUIRE LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICIALS AND HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS TO COLLECT AND SHARE
PUBLIC HEALTH DATA. WITH
STANDARDIZED AND DISAGGREGATED
DATA BASED ON RACE ETHNICITY
AND LANGUAGE. WE NEED TO HAVE
PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSES TO BE
MORE DATA DRIVEN TO BE MORE
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE- THIS-
MEASURES RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN ASSEMBLY WITH NO
OPPOSITION- I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WILL NOW MOVE TO
ANYONE WANTING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT LET'S BEGIN- THERE'S
NOBODY. IN ROOM ONE TWELVE OR
IN THE GALLERY WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO WITNESS WAITING TESTIFY VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE ORBIS-
MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT- AB. THIRTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT. LADIES AND GENTLEMAN TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE'S
KEYPAD. ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
QUEUED UP. THE FIRST LITTLE
LINE NUMBER FORTY TWO ONE FORTY
TWO YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON REBECCA
GONZALES NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER AND IN SUPPORT. THANKS
FOR ONLINE NUMBER EIGHTY GO
AHEAD PLEASE. KATHLEEN ARIANNA
ON BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA NORTH
COMPREHENSIVE CANCER CENTER AND
SUPPORT. HELLO NOT ALIGNED
NUMBER EIGHTY ONE I'M GOING TO.
NO WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. BLIND. TWENTY MY
NAME IS DR CAMERAS AND THE
PHYSICIAN DISPARITIES
RESEARCHER AND FOUNDER OF THE
MODE TO HELP THE COMMUNITY
BASED COMPANY NINETEEN TACTIC
CARE AND VACCINATION
COLLABORATIVE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND I JUST WANT TO
RE EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
DISAGGREGATED DATA I'M IN
PARTICULAR IN ORDER TO GET TO
THE- UNDERSTANDING OF THE ROOT
CAUSES OF THE DISPARITY THAT
CODE NINETEEN HAS SHOWN US-
INTO DRIVE EQUITABLE AND MORE
EFFICIENT ALLOCATION OF
RESOURCES FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
AND SPECIFICALLY PRECISION
PUBLIC HEALTH INTERVENTIONS. I
WOULD MENTION TO FILIPINOS DO
NOT GET CALLED OUT IN ANY OF
THE DATA THAT IS REPORTED
DESPITE REPRESENTING 20% OF
CALIFORNIA'S ASIAN
SUBPOPULATIONS THAT 3240% OF
THE KOBE DEATH AND IMPORTANTLY
ON THE FRONT LINES IN HEALTH
CARE FILIPINO THE ONLY
REPRESENT 4% OF THE NURSING
WORKFORCE BUT ONE THIRD OF THE
NURSES WHO HAVE DIED FROM KOBE.
IF WE FAIL TO RECOUP REQUIRE
DISAGGREGATED DATA COLLECTION
RESOURCES FOR THE ASIAN
COMMUNITY MAY BE LIMITED AND
WILL DIMINISH VACCINE ACCESS
AND OTHER MITIGATION STRATEGIES
NEEDED TO DEFEAT CODE IN HARD
HIT BUT YET COULD VERY HIDDEN
BY THE DATA POPULATION AND AS
YOU KNOW PERSISTENCE OF THE
PANDEMIC IN ANY COMMUNITY THE
RISK FOR PERSISTENT TO THE
PANDEMIC TO THE REST OF THE
STATE I PLEASE ASK. FOR YOUR I.
BOATS ON A. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU KNOWLEDGEABLE
NUMBER EIGHTY TWO YOUR OPEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN THIS IS FRED NOPE
WHERE REPRESENTING STANFORD
HEALTH CARE IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
WHAT AND THE FINAL REMINDER TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN PRESS ONE ZERO WE'RE
NOW ONLINE NUMBER EIGHTY THREE
YEAR OLD GO AHEAD PLEASE.
ANDREA RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MR SURELY HAVE NO ADDITIONAL
COLLAGEN SUPPORT. THANK YOU-
MODERATOR HAVING HER FOR THE
SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IT HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY SEEING
NONE NONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TESTIFIED VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE OR THIS
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
BABY SKEWS MAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF TA THANK YOU MR
CHAIR TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF THE THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE'RE GOING ON A LINE NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
WHERE AFTER CARRYING OUT THE.
THE FINAL REMINDER TO COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION OF A. B. THIRTEEN
FIFTY PRESS ONE ZERO PLEASE. MR
TRUMP ANNOUNCEMENT THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL CUES. THAT WILL
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
OUR MEMBERS- SENATOR GLAZER.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR. YOU KNOW
FOR A FOR A FOR SO MANY OF US
WHO HAVE SURVIVED THIS PANDEMIC
AND- ALMOST SIXTY THREE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS DID NOT.
THE COMMON POINT OF DISCUSSION
AND QUESTIONS THAT. I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN IS THAT. IS THE ONE
THAT GOES WHAT CAN WE DO
DIFFERENTLY. WHAT COULD WE HAVE
KNOWN. THAT COULD OF MADE OUR
ACTIONS. ARE MORE SUCCESSFUL
AND SAVE LIVES. AND AT THE
HEART OF THAT QUESTION IS THE
ISSUE OF DATA. AND THE
COLLECTION OF DATA AND THE
ABILITY TO ANALYZE THE DATA.
AND AND IT HAD A PRISCILLA LOOK
PRECISION THAT COULD GUIDE. THE
WHO'S GETTING INFECTED WHERE.
AND WHAT CAN WE DO ABOUT IT AND
SO THIS BILL REALLY TOUCH IS A
TOUCHDOWN ON WHAT I HOPE WILL
BE A- A- ONGOING EFFORT BY
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS SUCH AS
THIS AUTHOR. AND OTHERS TO.
REALLY DIG DOWN IN THIS SPACE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN DO
THIS. DATA COLLECTION BETTER
SMARTER AND MORE EFFECTIVELY
AND WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
SPLIT THE BILL TODAY HAPPY TO
MOVE IT. AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. GET A MOTION- BY SENATOR
GLAZER- MR A MEMBERS TO CHI
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH RESPECT- HE
SHOULD BE COMING FROM CENTER
GLASER AND- I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY ONE OTHER POINT I THINK
I KNOW THAT THERE WAS A CONCERN
RAISED ABOUT- PRIVACY A. B. R.
COMEDIAN ELSE'S DOES POINT OUT
THAT THE- CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH- SHOPPER
REQUIRED TO. EXCLUDE ANY
PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION AND ONLY AGGREGATED
ANONYMIZED DATA WOULD BE MADE
PUBLIC SO- WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR GUIDANCE.
THANK YOU THE BOOZE THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
GLAZER- THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO HEALTH COMMITTEE. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MR
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FOR A LOT OF ELEVEN
EIGHTY THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT DOT
HI DONNA HI NELSON RIGHT NELSON
HI ALAN. ALLEN I ARCHULETA HI
OR TO LET ICE BANKER. GORGEOUS
BRADFORD BLAZER HI PLEASE R. I.
Y. SO. JONES NO JONES NO
CATALOGUER. EMAIL ADDRESS THERE
ARE CURRENTLY NO. TWO POINT
ZERO I. RUBIO HI RIO I WILL
LOOK. SEVEN ONE SEVEN. OKAY
IT'S SEVEN ONE THAT BILL- BE ON
CALL. LOOKS LIKE WE'RE GOING
BACK NOW TO
. FIFTY PILOT OF
NUMBER NINE EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY
THREE ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AGAIN AND COLLEAGUES I
WANT TO BEGIN BY THANKING YOUR
COMMITTEE TAFF FOR THE
DILIGENCE ON THE ANALYSIS THE
BEST RECOMMENDATION STOPPING
VERY BRIEF THE BILL AUTHORIZES
PUBLIC ENTITIES TEND TO REQUIRE
CONTRACTORS INTO WORK FORCE
AGREEMENTS AS DEFINED FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS RELATED
TO BATTERY MANUFACTURING AND
LET HIM BASED TECHNOLOGIES IN
THE SALTON SEA GEOTHERMAL
RESOURCE AREA RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU- I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE JOHN WHITE HERE IN THE
GALLERY FOR SUPPORT MISTER
WHITE. PLEASE PROCEED. I'M NOT
MISTER WHITE OKAY- IS MISTER
WHITE ON THE LINE. SO I DON'T
THINK HE'S HERE THAT'S FINE IS
THERE ANYBODY ELSE- ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
PROCEED. IN SUPPORT. OF MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL. WE DO SUPPORT
THE EFFORT THE CELL NUMBERS
MAKING WITH THIS ILL WE- HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE WAY THE BILL
IS WRITTEN RIGHT NOW. WE ARE
ENJOYING A PRODUCTIVE
RELATIONSHIP WITH HIM AND A
STAFF TO WORK THROUGH THOSE
CONCERNS- WE SHARE THE GOAL OF
MAKING SURE THE- NEARLY TWENTY
FOUR HUNDRED OF OUR MEMBERS AND
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY APPRENTICES
IN HIS DISTRICT ARE EMPLOYED.
IN THIS INDUSTRY- THE SEVEN
THERE'S BEEN A LEADER ON MAKING
SURE THAT OCCURS AS WELL WE
APPRECIATE THOSE EFFORTS- WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
LANGUAGE IS WRITTEN THAT THE
RIGHT WAY- HE HAS INDICATED HE
WANTS TO WORK WITH US WE
APPRECIATE THAT AS WELL AND
LOOK FORWARD TO- CONTINUES
CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE WISHING TO-
SPEAK- THAT WILL MOVE AWAY
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF A. B. NINE
EIGHTY THREE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN PHILLIPS TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. NINETY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME ON YOUR PHONE'S KEYPAD.
ONE MOMENT WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT WE'RE GOING
ON THE LINE SEVENTY FIVE. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS MADELINE
COOPER ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA OUR
POSITION HAS CHANGED FROM PORT
AMENDED TO CONCERNS ON EIGHTY
NINE EIGHTY THREE THESE
CONCERNS ARE OUTLINED IN OUR
LETTER AND WE LOOK FORWARD YOU
ARE MORE PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATION BUT THE AUTHOR
GOING FORWARD THANK YOU. THIS
YEAH YEAH. FINAL REMINDER TO.
SUPPORT A NINETY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. MISTER CHAIR
WITHOUT ENOUGH THAT THERE ARE
NO ADDITIONAL COLLEGE IF YOU
THANK YOU MODERATOR- APPRECIATE
THAT HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS WITH THE
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY SCENE
NOW AND WE'RE SEEING THAT IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE- MODERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE. OPEN THE
LINES OF PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB NINETY THREE
PLEASE. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
COMMON OPPOSITION TO BE NINETY
THREE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME PLEASE. WE DO HAVE ONE
QUEUING UP IT'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF A. B.
NINETY THREE PRESS ONE ZERO
LINE NUMBER FORTY SIX YOUR OPEN
THE STORE AT. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RICHARD MARCUS AND
FOR THE WESTERN ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION IN THE
PLUMBING HEATING COOLING
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA. IN
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
ARTICULATED IN THE ANALYSIS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE
STRUCTURE WE HAVE NO ADDITIONAL
CALLINGTON KEYS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- SO NOW WILL- BRING IT
BACK TO THE MEMBERS FOR
DISCUSSION. ANY MEMBERS WISHING
TO DISCUSS ANYTHING THEY HAVE A
MOTION- WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THIS BILL. SENATOR GLAZER THANK
YOU- IT THIS CENTER OF SKEWS ME
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA WOULD
LIKE CLOSE THANK YOU AGAIN AND
RESPECT YOU HAVE FOR EXAMPLE
THANK YOU- THIS BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR GLAZER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE. SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NINE EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY THREE DOT. HI DONNA HI
NIELSEN NO NO SAYING NO ALAN.
HI ALLEN HI ARCHULETA. HI
ARCHULETA HI BECKER GORGEOUS
BRADFORD LATER GLASER ALRIGHT
WESSEL JONES CAN LONGER
MELENDEZ FOURTEEN TO NO I WANT
TO KNOW I. RUBIO I WILL I WILL.
JONES NO. SIXTY TWO GERMAN
THAT'S SIX EYES TO NOSE WHEEL
PLACES BILL ON CALL. FOR NOW.
GOING TO MOVE TO A SEVEN MEMBER.
CUNNINGHAM FILE TEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN- AB TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN
CUNNINGHAM YOU MAY BEGIN THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN BRUCE AB TWELVE
SIXTY SEVEN CLARIFIES THAT AN
ALCOHOL BEVERAGE MANUFACTURER
CAN ADVERTISE AND DONATE A
PORTION OF THE PROCEEDS OF THE
SALE OF THE BEVERAGE TO A
NONPROFIT CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATION. EXAMPLES COULD
INCLUDE DONATING A PERCENTAGE
OF THE COST OF A BOTTLE OF WINE
TO BENEFIT WILDFIRE RECOVERY
CODE RECOVERY OCEAN CLEANUP
ANIMAL SHELTERS US VETERANS
SERVICES FOOD BANKS AND A HOST
OF OTHER WORTHY CAUSES. THE
ALCOHOL BEVERAGE CONTROL
DEPARTMENT HAS INTERPRETED
CURRENT LAW CURRENT LAWS
PROHIBITING GIVING A PREMIUM
GIFT.OR FREE GOOD IN
CONNECTION WITH THE SALE BUT
THEY HAVE TEMPORARILY WAIVED
ENFORCEMENT THIS RULE DURING
COVERT FOR COVE IN RELATED
CONTRIBUTIONS THIS BILL WILL
CODIFY THE TEMPORARY PRACTICE
AND EXPAND IT TO OTHER
CHARITABLE CAUSES. WE ASKED FOR
AND I VOTE I BELIEVE WE HAVE
TEN SMELTZER WITH THE WINE
INSTITUTE- TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF. THE SMELTER YOU MAY BEGIN
IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE. OKAY HE
IS NOT ON THE LINE- LET'S IS
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES THE
GALAXY NINE. ARE THERE ANY-
WOULD. WELL THEY'RE JUST GOT ON
THE LINE SIR. ALL RIGHT PERFECT
THIS SPELLED CERTAIN DOOM
BEGINS. ALL RIGHT YEAH-
INTENTIONAL THERE WITH WINE
INSTITUTE. AND PROBABLY THE
TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN ARBIL NEXT
MODESTLY EXPAND OUR ABILITY TO
SUPPORT CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATIONS AND WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE OTHER
IS NOBODY AND ROOM ONE TWELVE.
AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO WHAT THIS
IS WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR COULD
YOU- PROMPT INDIVIDUALS-
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF A B. TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF A BEACH BALL
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PONE'S
KEYPAD DURING THE GOING OUT TO
LINE NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHT MORE
OPEN. LOOKS THANK YOU KAREN
MEMBERS TIFFANY MARK ON BEHALF
OF CAL NOT PROFIT WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AT TWELVE SIXTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY FIVE
YEAR OLD. HI MISTER CHAIR CHRIS
WALKER OF THE HALF THE
CALIFORNIA CRAFT BREWERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU AND ONCE
AGAIN WITH THE GENTLEMAN TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF A B.
TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN PRESS ONE
ZERO LIVING ON ADELINE FIFTY TO
GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD MORNING
MARKED THE HEIGHT DO I MEAN
HALF OF THE FAMILY WINEMAKERS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL CALLS IN QUEUE.
THANK YOU MODERATOR. HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WILL
NOW FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN
HERE FROM OPPOSITION NO
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY NO
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE-
WILL NOW MOVE ON AND ASKED THE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROPPED INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF TWELVE
SIXTY. EIGHT B. TWELVE SIXTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIR TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO THE B.
TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN PLUS ONE
ZERO PLEASE WE ARE GOING OUT TO
LINE FIFTY SIX GOING TO. GOOD
MORNING THIS CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MICHAEL SKIP ON
BEHALF OF ALCOHOL JUSTICE. WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANKS THANK YOU. FINAL
REMINDER REPRESENTATION FIRST.
ONE ZERO. AND WITH THAT AMOUNT
OF MOISTURE WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL CALLS IN QUEUE THANK
YOU TO ALL OR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOT
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
THE MEMBERS. ANY MEMBER WISHING
TO ADDRESS THIS BILL SENATOR
GLAZER. THANK YOU MR CHAIR AT
THAT THINK THIS BILL HAS THE
PROPER PROTECTIONS- FOR THE
PROPOSAL THAT'S BEFORE US AND
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT MOVE IT FOR
FREE TIME. WAS THAT A MOTION
MISSED CIRCULARS ARE OKAY. SO
WE HAVE A MOTION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- CUTTING HIM WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE HIS RESPECT FOR
ASTRONOVA THANK YOU SIR- THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
GLAZER THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN DOT. DONNA I NELSON HIGH
NELSON ALL RIGHT ALLEN. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I'D BETTER.
BECKER I BOARD JUST BORDERS I
BRADFORD LATER LATER I WENT SO.
JONES HI JONES HI KEN LONGER.
MELENDEZ PUT INTO YOU KNOW I
WANT TO KNOW I. RUBIO HI REVEAL
I WILL. THAT'S TEN ZERO
TERMINAL CALL. THE BILL IS- TEN
ZERO OR IN OUR CALL I'M GONNA
CALL FOR JUST A VERY SHORT
RECESS THANK YOU THE SEVEN
MEMBER KENNY I THINK IN THE
SHORT RECESS PLEASE.
THE GEO
COMMITTEE WILL COME BACK TO
ORDER. AT THIS TIME- AT THIS
TIME WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR A. B. THREE THREE
EIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF OUR
RAMEAU'S. WHEN YOU'RE READY YOU
MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. I HAVE BEFORE
YOU TODAY A BILL AB THREE THREE
EIGHT A MEASURE TO BRING
FORWARD THE VOICE OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE ON AN
ISSUE OF MISTREATMENT AND IT
KNOWLEDGE MEANT OF A HORRID
PAST OF THE STATE'S HISTORY ONE
THAT BROUGHT ATROCITIES AND
GENOCIDE TO CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
PEOPLE. VERY LITTLE OF
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
SLAVERY DURING THE MISSION
PERIOD IS CAPTURED IN OUR
HISTORY BOOKS. THE SPANISH
MISSIONARIES AND THE MILITARY
SUB DUDE AND ENSLAVED
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICANS TO
FORCED LABORS AND DISPLACED
FAMILY MEMBERS IN THEIR QUEST
TO COLONIZE THE ALREADY
INHABITED CALIFORNIA. THE
MENTALITY THAT CARRIED FORWARD
TO THE STATE'S EARLIEST LEADERS
WITH THE FIRST GOVERNOR SETTING
PAID BOUNTIES TO FORM MILITIAS
AIDED AIDED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- EMBARKED ON A
DELIBERATE POLICY OF GENOCIDE
AS DEFINED BY POST HOLOCAUST
HUMAN RIGHTS TRIBUNALS. FATHER
SERRA SERVES AS THAT CONSTANT
REMINDER OF THAT ERA OF VIEWING
CALIFORNIA INDIANS AS LESS THAN
HUMAN. SOME ARGUE THE FATHER
SERRA SHOULD NOT BE JUDGED BY
TODAY'S VALUES HOWEVER IN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SIX FRENCH
MAYBE CAPTAIN JEAN FRANCIS DE
GAULLE UPON ARRIVING IN
MONTEREY BAY. WAS APPALLED BY
THE MISSIONARIES ABUSE OF
NATIVE AMERICANS RIDING
CORPORAL PUNISHMENT IS
INFLICTED ON THE INDIANS OF
BOTH SEXES WHO NEGLECT THE
ACCESSIBILITY AND MANY SINS
WHICH IN EUROPE. ARE LEFT TO
DIVINE JUSTICE IN HERE IN
MONTEREY THEY WERE PUNISHED BY
IRONS AND STOCKS THAT WAS IN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SIX. IN A
TWENTY FIFTEEN POPE FRANCIS
HIMSELF APOLOGIZE FOR THE MANY
GRAVE SINS COMMITTED AGAINST
THE NATIVE PEOPLES OF AMERICA
AND ASK FOR FORGIVENESS. WITH
ME TODAY ARE TO TRAVEL CHAIRS
TO GIVE THEIR VOICE TO THIS
PROCESS TODAY A VOICE THAT WAS
INTENTIONALLY LEFT OUT OF THE
PROCESS IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN. WITH ME TODAY MISTER
CHAIRMAN TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
IS CHAIRWOMAN REGINA CUELLAR OF
THE SHINGLE SPRINGS RANCHERIA
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT AND CHAIRMAN
HEY SUSE TO WRANGLE OF THE
WILTON RANCH RANCHERIA TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT. CHAIRMAN TARANGO
ARE YOU ON THE LINE. YES I AM
PLEASE PROCEED SIR. A DIFFICULT
TO BE UPSET THE SUIT BUT-
GERMAN DOT AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS PACERS
TARANGO NOT DETERMINABLE
RANCHERIA I'M HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT. IT
HAS BEEN MY HONOR TO WORK WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAMES RUMBLES
IN THE FIVE SPONSORING TRYING
ON THE SUPPORT LEGISLATION. MY
TRIBE HAS INHABITED THE AREA
NOW KNOWN AS THE SACRAMENT OF
VALUE. VALLEY THE TIME
IMMEMORIAL MY ANCESTORS FOUGHT
TO PROVIDE THE GENOCIDE THE
CALIFORNIA INDIANS CAUSED BY
THE SPANISH MISSIONARY SYSTEM.
THE MEXICAN AND AMERICAN
MILITARY INCURSIONS AND THE
NEWLY FORMED CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT. THAT I SIT HERE
BEFORE YOU TODAY I WANT TO BE
CLEAR. THIS IS ABOUT MORE THAN
ONE A BETTER SIR AS IMPORTANT
AS IT IS. EIGHTY THREE THIRTY
EIGHT IT'S JUST ONE STEP
TOWARDS THE RECONCILIATION THE
PAINFUL PAST THE INDIGENOUS ME
WALK IN THE NOT PEOPLE BUT THE
SACRAMENTO REGION. AND THE
INDIGENOUS. POPULATION ACROSS
THE ENTIRE STATE. WHAT A BETTER
WAS NOT A GOOD MAN. WHILE WE DO
NOT KNOW HIS TRUE INTENTIONS.
THE CONSEQUENCES OF HIS CTIONS
ON MY ANCESTORS ARE
INDISPUTABLE. GOOD MEN DO NOT
AUTHORIZE THE BOOK OF IDEATION
OF MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN. IN
AN ATTEMPT TO PURIFY THE BODY
TO STAND IN THEIR WAY OF LIFE.
GOOD MEN DID NOT BUILD A SYSTEM
BY WHICH INDIGENOUS PEOPLE WERE
RIPPED AWAY FROM THEIR HOMES.
AND FORCED INTO HARD LABOR FOR
A REGION THAT SADDAM HAS SENT
HIM. THROUGH THE WHOLE THE
ENTIRE NARRATIVE ABOUT WHO
LOOKED AT IT THERE AND HE'S
WORKING AS A PUBLIC
CONSTRAINING. IS ABOUT A MUCH
LARGER SYSTEM OF OPPRESSION THE
FACT THAT DECIMATE CALIFORNIA'S
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE. THE
CALIFORNIA MISSION SYSTEM IS
WITHOUT A DOUBT A CHAPTER OF
THE STATE ISSUE THAT NEEDS
TELLING. BUT THE STORY MUST BE
ACCURATE. BY REMOVING THE
STATUES WE ARE NOT ATTEMPTING
TO REWRITE HISTORY. IT'S QUITE
THE OPPOSITE IN FACT WE ARE
ASKING THE CALIFORNIA HISTORY
BE TOLD IN A TRUTHFUL AND
HONEST MANNER. FOR GENERATIONS
STUDENTS HAVE LEARNED ABOUT THE
MISSION SYSTEM AND THE
BENEVOLENCE TOWARD INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE. THESE WEAPONS INCLUDING
FALSE AND INCOMPLETE NARRATIVE
THAT NATIVE PEOPLE WERE SAVED
BY THE MISSION AND THAT THE
RESIDENT THERE WITH MY CHOICE.
THESE WEAPONS ALMOST ALTOGETHER
DENIED THE INJUSTICE. VIOLENCE
AND GENOCIDE THAT OCCURRED AS
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA MISSION
SYSTEM. THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY OUR
CHILDREN DESERVE MORE. AS WE
LOOK TO BUILD A MORE JUST AND
EQUITABLE FUTURE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. WE MUST
TELL AN ACCURATE HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA'S FOUND. REMOVING
HER PREDECESSOR AND OTHERS LIKE
HIM SUCH AS JOHN STARTER KIT
CARSON FROM THEIR ELEVATED
STATUS IS ONLY THE BEGINNING OF
TELLING STORIES THAT INCLUSIVE
OF ALL PLACES IN CALIFORNIA.
ALL TOO OFTEN IN AMERICAN
HISTORY THE OPPRESSIVE WRITE
THE NARRATIVE OF THE OPPRESSED.
WHY IS THAT CHILDREN ACROSS
CALIFORNIA CAN EASILY NAME OFF
THE THREE SHIPS COLUMBUS FAILED
BUT HAVE NO IDEA WHICH TRIBE
OCCUPIED THE LAND. IS BACK. LET
ALONE ANY OF THE CALIFORNIA
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE WHO HAVE
FOUGHT AGAINST ALL ODDS TO KEEP
OUR CULTURE. LANGUAGE AND
TRADITIONS ALIVE. EIGHTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT TAKES FIRST STEP
TOWARD. AN ACTOR HISTORY THE
PART OF THE DEAL PEOPLE. BY
REMOVING ONE OF THE SERVICE.
REMOVING REMINDER OF THE
VIOLENT. AGAINST PEOPLE
INDIGENOUS TO THE STATE. MY
PEOPLE. INSTEAD OF BEING RE.
THAT THEIR ANCESTORS WERE
VICTIMS OF THE VIOLENCE SYSTEMS
START TO STRIP THEM OF THEIR
IDENTITY AND CULTURE. WE CAN
BEGIN TO TELL A NARRATIVE OF
RESILIENCE IN THE FACE OF
ADVERSITY AND THE TYRANT. THAT
WILL ALLOW FOR NATIVE PEOPLE.
PARTICULARLY YOU. TO FILL OUT
THAT THEIR IDENTITY AND VOICES
ARE VALID IN TODAY'S SOCIETY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. EIGHTY THREE THIRTY
EIGHT FUNGAL. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN TO. WATCHER WE GUY
QUITE YOUR- ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
YES I AM PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
DAUGHTER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS REGINA
CUELLAR CHAIRWOMAN OF THE
SHINGLE SPRINGS BAND OF MIWOK
INDIANS. THE INDIGENOUS HISTORY
IN THE SACRAMENTO AREA AND IF
PEOPLE ARE RICH IN HERITAGE
CULTURE AND TRADITION THIS AREA
WAS VIEWED AS A BETTER
CONDITIONAL ECONOMICS OR MONEY
ON POLITICAL POWER AND NEEDED
TO CHANGE OUR PRIVATE INDUSTRY
INCLUDE NISSAN ME WALK AND MY
D. LINEAGE WHICH DIRECTLY
CONNECTS OUR COMMUNITY TO VERY
DILIGENT AND HOMELAND ALONG IN
BETWEEN THE RIVERS IN THE AREA.
ONE OF THE KINDS OF PERMANENT
PRIMARY VILLAGE FISHING IS
LOCATED AT PRESENT DAY
DISCOVERY PARK THE LAND WHICH
THE CAPITAL OCCUPIED TODAY THE
HOME OF THE SOVEREIGN PEOPLE
WHO ENTERED INTO BY THE EARLY
DECADES OF STATEHOOD IN WHICH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WAS
COMPLICIT IN AN ACT OF VIOLENCE
EXPLOITATION AND ATTEMPTED
DESTRUCTION OF TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES. THESE COMMUNITIES
AND THE MANY TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
WITHIN CALIFORNIA HAVE REMAINED
COMMITTED TO THE STEWARDSHIP OF
THIS PLAN SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF TIME AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
DO SO THE STATE CAPITOL GROUNDS
SERVICE AN AREA TRADITIONALLY
VERY FROM MORAL AND MONUMENTS I
WILL BE CONSULTED IN. NINETEEN
SIXTY THREE WE WOULD HAVE
SHARED. I DON'T DOUBT AS
CRITICAL ROLE IN THIS IN. OF
NATIVE IN AS- IT IMPERATIVE
THAT WE HAVE THE- ECONOMY IN.
HOW CALLERS STORY. ABC EIGHT
ONE OFFERING TRIBAL. IN CONCORD
WITH THE STATE TO PLAN.
CONSTRUCT AND MAINTAIN A
MONUMENT ON THE GROUNDS OF THE
STATE CAPITOL THIS.
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT IT'S
CRITICAL TO ENSURE APPROVAL.
EIGHTY THREE THREE EIGHT IT'S A
GREAT FIRST STEP IN A LONG
PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT NATIVE
AMERICAN VOICES ARE HEARD WHEN
THE TIME IS RIGHT TO READ A
MONUMENT THAT PROPERLY
REPRESENTS OUR CULTURAL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THIS REGION.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
ALLOWING US TO SHAR OUR
TESTIMONY WE THINK IT'S
NORMALLY MEMBER ALMOST RINGING
AT THREE THREE EIGHT FORWARD.
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT. EIGHTY
THREE GREAT THANK YOU. OKAY WE
HAVE A WITH UP THE GALLERY WHEN
YOU'RE READY YOU CAN PROCEED.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN DON MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FRANK MOLINA
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN MANUEL
BAND OF MISSION INDIANS AND THE
CENTER'S BAD ISSUE MENTIONED IN
SOME STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MOLINA-
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. I WILL NOW- UP
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
THREE THREE EIGHT. AGAIN TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR A. B. THREE
THREE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWEDBY THE ZERO ONE EIGHT
PDF FREE WILL GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER. OFF LINE IN THE PLACE
BACK IN THE QUEUE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR A. B.
THREE THREE EIGHT. A NUMBER TO
AN ALKALINE EIGHTY NINE FIRST
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR AND MEMBER
SOVIET POLICE SHOT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. FIVE SEVENTY YOUR OPEN. MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRIS K. R. O. ON
BEHALF OF CHICKENRANCH
RANCHERIA THE TWO ON ME THAN ME
WHAT TRIBE THE PRESIDENT AND
THEN THE NON LACKEY INDIANS IN
WILTON RANCHERIA WE ON STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR OPEN
PLEASE ON MUTE. YOU HEAR IT.
MOVE ON THE LINE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS AFRIKA BURGERS AND ON
BEHALF OF RECOGNITION RIA ALSO-
ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND MY
FAMILY WE ARE NOT OPEN WORLD
MEMBER OF THE- KLAMATH TRIBES
AND- WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF STUFF
LIKE. NINE SIXTY FOUR YOU ARE
UP PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS LUCY FEAR I CAN LEARN-
I AM LOCATED SISTERS CIRCLE
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND NATIVE
THAT MEANT WE'RE HIGHLY IN THE
POOR- THANK YOU. NINE FORTY
THREE YOU ARE UP PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO ON BEHALF OF THE
TRIBAL LINES TO START IN THE
NATION'S TOP IN. I AM CALLING
IN SUPPORT ON A. B. THREE THREE
EIGHT. ALL OF THE STEPS TOWARD
RICK RECONCILIATION HELPED TURN
THE PAGE ON A DARK CHAPTER OF
THE STATE HISTORY. WE ARGUE I.
THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ANGELINA HINOJOSA- I AM A
NATIVE AMERICAN YOUTH WITHIN
SACRAMENTO AND I SUPPORT. FINED
EIGHTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. IT'S
REGARDING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO THE CREDIT FROM
THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL THEIR
COMPLIANCE POPPING UP THE
POLICY AND THE MISSION INDIANS
PICKING RANCHERIA THE CZECH
CHAMPIONS I AM DOWN TO ME WALK
INDIANS IN A TAURUS MARTINEZ
DESERT AHUILLA INDIANS WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE CURRENT FORM.
EIGHTY THREE THREE EIGHT THANK
YOU. FINE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE
CALL AT. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
YES WE CAN. HI ANNA ILLINOIS IT
MERRY BUT ON THOSE CONCERNS THE
COCKPIT LOOKING RANCHERIA GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBER AND
CHAIRMAN OF AMERICA DOWNLOAD
TRIBAL ELDER AND FORMER
CHAIRWOMAN OF THE WILTON
RANCHERIA AND I'M STRONG AND I
AM A STRONG SUPPORT AT EIGHTY
THREE THREE EIGHT CAN YOU CALL
THANK YOU SENATE COMMITTEE
MEMBER. DAN DAN IT'S ONLY WHEN
RONALD. THANK YOU ADELINE
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. OUR
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHTY EIGHT.
TEN YEARS PLEASE UNMUTE. THANK
YOU WHEN I GOT OUT OF AN EIGHTY
EIGHT- I APOLOGIZE- LANE NINETY
TWO MUCH TAKEN THEMSELVES OUT
AT YOU TO REACH YOU PLEASE. ONE
ZERO NINETY TWO AND WE WILL GO
TO NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BILL HUNTER ON BEHALF OF YOUR
TODAY HE WENT TO NATION PROBLEM
RECORD. EIGHTY ONE THREE THREE
THREE THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
AND I'LL- NINETY TWO WAS
BACKING Q. PLEASE GO AT NINETY
TWO. YES A PUBLIC STREET- ON
THE HALF OF THE CHILD AND THE
CALUSA TRIED IN OPEN COURT. AND
FOR ADDITIONAL- SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME FOR A. B. THREE THREE
EIGHT. NINETY SIX YOU ARE OUT.
MORE AN ANTENNA ARRAYS TRIBAL
COUNCIL WORKING RANCHERIA AND
I'M STRONG COURT OF A. B. THREE
THREE EIGHT. THANK YOU NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES GO AHEAD. HI CONNIE I GOT
THAT RAIN OCCURRING THOUGH I AM
HAVE A GOLDEN RETRIEVER
DEPARTMENT OF TRIBAL HEALTH AND
INDIGENOUS MOTHER AND MOTHER
AND HE WALKED OVER AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT EIGHTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR NO LOOK AT THE
PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR-
YEP NOW THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM-
THE WITNESSES FOR WOULD YOU- I
SEE NOBODY IN THE CHAMBER HERE
WISHING TO- TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NOBODY IN
ROUTE ROOM ONE TWELVE MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. TO AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHT. THANK YOU AGAIN TO
SHOW OPPOSITION FOR EIGHTY
THREE THIRTY EIGHT. EACH PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE
WILL START WITH ONE FORTY NINE.
ONE FORTY NINE CORRECT. HI I'M
CALLING IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION AND SINCE THERE WAS
NOT A PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION I'M ASKING FOR A FEW
MOMENTS TO READ SOMETHING BY
JOHN FAIRBANKS A PRISONER OF
THE CATHEDRAL OF THE BLESSED
SACRAMENT IN FACT IN FACT
CRIMINAL ACT- A WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL YOU HAVE
A SHOW READING FROM JOHN DEERE
SKEWS ME SO READING FROM CHILD
CARE MA'AM. I AM PLEASED.
WHAT'S YOU HAVE TO MAKE
PROVISION YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
FOR BUILDING MONUMENT. HEY
THANK YOU IN READING FROM JOHN
FAIRBANKS WRITTEN TESTIMONY
FROM CALMATTERS. IN FEBRUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE READING FROM
HIS STATEMENT I APPLAUD A. B.
THREE THREE EIGHT PROVISIONS
FOR BUILDING MONUMENTS IN HONOR
OF CALIFORNIAN NATIVE PEOPLE IN
CATHOLIC SOCIAL TEACHING- THE
COMMODIOUS BOWLS AND PROVISION
AS OPPOSED TO A LIMITING EITHER
OR PROPOSITION BOTH MEMORIALS
TO NATIVE PEOPLES AND SARAH CAN
RESIDE TOGETHER IN CAPITOL PARK
AND THERE WILL STILL BE PLENTY
OF ROOM FOR HONORING OTHERS. IN
CONTINUING TO READ FROM JOHN
FAIRBANKS. THANK THE EVILS OF
SCRIBE TO FATHER SERRA AND THE
FRANCISCAN MISSIONARY MOVEMENT
IN CALIFORNIA DURING THE
EIGHTEENTH CENTURY ARE
MISPLACED SURE HE WASN'T
PERFECT AND HIS MESSAGE OF THE
VANDALISM OR HARSH WHEN JUDGED
BY TODAY'S STANDARDS. BUT
OVERALL HE IN THE MISSION OR A
FORCE FOR GOOD GOD KNOWS THAT
THE CATHOLIC CHURCH IS NOT
PERFECT THE MELANCHOLY I FEEL
WHEN THINKING ABOUT THEIR THE
STATUTE IS THIS TRAUMA MINOR
CHORD IN COMPARISON TO THE
TRAGIC OPERA THE MOTIONS
RESOUNDING WHEN I THINK ABOUT
OUR CLERGY DIABOLICALLY ABUSING
THE INNOCENT SOUL OUT TO
PROTECT NEVERTHELESS THE
CATHOLIC CHURCH IS INFINITELY
CAPACIOUS. MAKING ROOM FOR
SAINTS AND SINNERS A LIGHT WELL
NOT INFINITE CALIFORNIA IS
CAPACIOUS AS WELL IF WE CAN AND
WE WANT WE CAN MAKE ROOM FOR
ALL KINDS GOD HELP US IF WE'RE
ALWAYS PULLING AWAY FROM EACH
OTHER TEARING AT OUR COMMON
GENERATIONS FEARING THE OTHER
INSTEAD OF BEING CURIOUS AND
APPROACHING HIM OR HER WITH AN
OPEN HEART. GOD HELP US IF WE
CAN'T LAUGH AT OURSELVES AND
FIND FRIENDSHIP AMONG CRITICS
GOD HELP US RECOGNIZE THE
GREATNESS OF CALIFORNIA THE
MOST POPULOUS STATE IN THE
UNION WITH AN ABUNDANCE OF
WHITE SOUL WILLING TO WORK FOR
THE COMMON GOOD AGAIN I
REITERATE I APPLIED EIGHTY
THREE THREE EIGHT. PROVISION
FOR BUILDING MONUMENTS IN HONOR
OF CALIFORNIA'S NATIVE PEOPLE
BECAUSE IN THAT SPIRIT CATHOLIC
TEACHING DOES SAY BOTH AND NOT
EITHER OR THERE IS ROOM FOR
FATHER SERRA IN THE GARDEN AND
ALL AND ANY TRIBUTE TO NATIVE
PEOPLE AND OTHER GROUPS AS WELL
AGAIN I GIVE THIS CREDIT TO-
JOHN FAIRBANKS WRITTEN. IN
CALMATTERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE TIME. NEXT CALL
MODERATOR. THERE'S NOBODY ELSE
QUEUED UP MISTER CHAIR OKAY
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA- NOW
BRING THE DISCUSSION AND- BACK
TO THE MEMBER SINCE WE'VE
HEARD. ALL THE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. I DO WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SENATOR WAY SO. THANK YOU AND
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO
APPLAUD. THE EFFORT TO CREATE A
MONUMENT HERE RECOGNIZING IN
OUR NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY
AND- WITHIN IT. AWESOME
TECHNOLOGY MEANT THAT OF THESE
COMMUNITIES WERE DESTROYED THEY
WERE ABUSED. OVER THE YEARS-
BEGINNING WITH- JUST THE
COLONIZATION OF THIS WHOLE AREA
THERE WERE ENORMOUS ABUSES AND
THAT ONLY SEEM TO GET WORSE AS
YEARS WENT BY. AND IN
CALIFORNIA WE ACTUALLY HAD.
ORGANIZED GENOCIDE THAT WAS
UNDERTAKEN BY OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE STATE
GOVERNMENTS I MEAN A BOUNTY WAS
PUT ON ON ON THE HEADS OF
NATIVE AMERICANS AND THEY WERE
HUNTED DOWN. LOOK LIKE. IF AS
IF THEY WERE LESS THAN HUMANS
AND OFTEN LESS VALUABLE THAN
SOME LIVESTOCK AND IT'S A VERY
SAD HISTORY IN CALIFORNIA SO I
THINK IT'S VERY APPROPRIATE.
THAT WE DO SOMETHING HERE IN
THE IN THE CAPITAL I HAD ONE A
QUESTION ON FROM THE AUTHOR
RELATING TO FUNDING AND THERE
WAS A WHOLE SECTION THAT WAS
STRICKEN ON HOW THIS WAS. JUST
FROM THE I KNOW THE WAY THINGS
WORK IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. I WAS I WAS HOPING THE
STATE COULD PUT SOME MONEY
BEHIND THIS EFFORT AND HELP
CONSTRUCT THAT MONUMENT BUT
GENERALLY. THIS BILL WAS
AMENDED IN THE ASSEMBLY AND I
JUST WANTED TO KNOW IF YOU
COULD JUST BRIEFLY GIVE US A
REASON WHY. THE AREA WAS
AMENDED IN WHY WE CAN'T
PARTICIPATE FINANCIALLY IN THE
CREATION OF THIS MONUMEN SO I
WOULD SUPPORT THAT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ANALOGY OF
THE TREATMENT TOWARDS
CALIFORNIAN PEOPLE- BACK IN THE
HISTORY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO WHERE WE ARE NOW.
BASED ON THE FUNDING ASPECT OF
IT THERE WS MONEY THAT WAS SET
ASIDE. IN THE BUDGET- TO-
MAINTAIN- FATHER SAT AS
STATUTE. IT'S THAT PART OF THE
FUNDING THAT WAS TAKEN OUT. OF
THE BUDGET ITSELF. IN RULES
WHEN YOU'RE SIMPLY SIGN OKAY. I
WAS TAKEN OVER BY BUT- I MEAN
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
THAT BASICALLY REQUIRES THAT
THE FUNDING BE PROVIDED BY THE
TRIBAL COMMUNITY. THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS NEGOTIATED
AGREED TO OR WHAT WHAT WE
PROPOSE THAT ARE WHY WHY CAN'T
WE ENTERTAIN PROVIDING FUNDING
FOR THE MAINTENANCE THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THAT UP- MR
SENATOR- THAT PROVISION ALSO
WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS- PUT ON
IN RULES AS FAR AS THE
MAINTENANCE. AND FOLLOWING
OTHER MONUMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHED ON FOLLOWING
LANGUAGE FROM THE RONALD
REAGAN- STATUTE THAT MOVE
FORWARD SO KEEPING EVERYTHING
EVERYTHING AND PARITY. I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONCERN THAT THERE
SHOULD BE FUNDING FOR THAT
STATUE IN THE SOMETHING THAT I
WILL RELATE TO THOSE THAT ARE
ON THE CALL AND THOSE THAT ARE
THERE FOR YOUR SUPPORT MOVING
FORWARD IN THAT AND I KNOW THE
WAY THIS WORKS IF ONE HOUSE
AGREES TO THAT AND THERE'S A
AGREEMENT MADE THAT USUALLY WE
RESPECT THAT. AND HONOR THAT
BUT HAS AGREEMENT BEEN MADE I
MEAN IS THAT SOMETHING THAT'S
THE WAY IT WILL MOVE FORWARD ON
THE RULES COMMITTEE AND SO-
UNFORTUNATELY THAT PART OF. OUR
I WAS HOPING WE COULD DO
SOMETHING AND MAYBE AT A LATER
DATE WE CAN CONTRIBUTE TO THAT
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS
DIFFERENT THIS IS DIFFERENT
THERE TO A CERTAIN EXTENT. OUR
STATE HOUSE TO ATONE FOR OUR
HISTORY. AND IT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL TO DO IT THROUGH
ACTUAL- US SUPPORT FOR THE
CREATION. OF THIS- THE IS A
BLANK. IN THE- IT'S IN THE
BEGINNING OF THE BILL. AND IT'S
NOT ACTUALLY IN THE BODY OF THE
LANGUAGE AND YOU MENTIONED THAT
MONEY WAS TAKEN OUT THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS. NOT TO MAINTAIN-
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT AND DOES
THE REQUIREMENT TO MAINTAIN THE
PHONE IF THERE ARE SEVERAL. THE
MONUMENT BUT IN THIS BILL. IN
THE FIRST PAGE IT IT'S NOT
CONTAINED IN THE ACTUAL LETTER
PART OF THE BILL BUT THERE IS A
REFERENCE SAYING THAT THIS BILL
WOULD DELETE THE REQUIREMENT
RELATING TO THE- MONUMENT. TO A
FATHER COULD BE PROUDER OF
SEVEN. THAT WAS ADDED TO THE
BILL I MEAN THAT WAS THE
ORIGINAL- BUT THAT IS THE ONLY
REFERENCE THAT. CURRENTLY THAT
I KNOW OF THAT MAKES A
REQUIREMENT. THAT THE STATE
NEEDS TO CONTINUE- MAINTAINING
THE FATHER CONFIGURE SERVER
MONUMENT. IS THERE ANOTHER
REFERENCE SOMEWHERE ELSE AS FAR
AS THE- MAINTAINING IT AND THE-
CREATING. SOME TYPE OF
NONPROFIT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE MONEY TO PROVIDE FOR
THAT MONUMENT AND FOR THE
UPKEEP OF IT VISIT OUR OUR
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE HAD. GOING
INTO APPROPRIATIONS IT DEALS
WITH THE FUNDING COMPONENT OF
IT- SO IT DOES HAVE THAT- AS WE
MOVE FORWARD THROUGH THE
ASSEMBLY- AND NOW WE'RE AT
TODAY. YES SIR IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT- ALL THE
STATUES AND MONUMENTS. I
REQUIRE A PRIVATE FUNDING THAT
ALWAYS CAN BE CHANGED TO
CERTAINLY THROUGHOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS BUT THAT'S-
THE INCLUDING THE COOPER SEVEN
MONUMENT. YES OKAY BUT OF THIS
BILL MAKES REFERENCE TO DELETE
THE REQUIREMENT RELATING TO THE
MONUMENT OF PUTTING BETTER SIR
WHICH IS JUST TO MAINTAIN
MAINTAIN MEANS TO ALLOW IT TO
BE THERE SO IS IT YOUR INTENT
THROUGH THIS BILL TO REMOVE THE
CONFEDERATE CENTER MONUMENT. MY
INTENT THROUGH THIS BILL IS TO
GIVE THE CALIFORNIA PEOPLE THAT
SPOKE SO ELOQUENTLY ON THIS
BILL THE VOICE THAT WAS ABSENT
IN NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN IN THE
YEARS PRIOR TO THAT WHEN THE
MISSIONARY SYSTEM CAME FORWARD
THAT VOICE HAS NEVER BEEN HEARD
AS PART OF HISTORY OR EVEN THE
TRUE FACTUAL ASPECTS OF WHAT
HAS HAPPENED YOU'VE HEARD MANY
PEOPLE ON THE CALL HERE TODAY
TO REAFFIRM THAT SO THIS BILL
IS ABOUT GIVING CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST PEOPLE. OF VOICE ONCE AND
FOR ALL THAT HAS BEEN- RACED
THROUGH THE HISTORY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA OF HAVING THAT
VOICE PRESENT SO HE'S A FIGMENT
DELETING 20% I WOULD GIVE THEM
A VOICE MR- SENATOR WE WENT WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS IN IN YOUR
ROOM BUT WE TALKED ABOUT GOING
BACK AND FORTH AND ONE OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WAS MADE. WAS
THAT- A RACING HISTORY AND I
DISAGREED WITH THAT BECAUSE
WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT WHEN
PELOSI HAD A COMING UP THERE
WAS A WHOLE HISTORY THAT WAS
RAISED AT THAT TIME IT'S THAT
HISTORY THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
LET THAT VOICE TO THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT TODAY THESE ARE
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT IS
GIVING THE VOICE BACK TO THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE IT'S NOT
ABOUT A RACING CULTURE MISTER
SENATOR IT'S ABOUT GIVING THEM
A VOICE TO THOSE. THAT HAVE NOT
HAD THE CHANCE TO HAVE THEIR
VOICE HEARD EVEN IN THESE
CHAMBERS BY EVEN HAVING THIS
DEBATE AND HAVING- SPEAKERS
CHIME IN IS THE MOST THAT WE'VE
SEEN CALIFORNIA ENDED PEOPLE'S
VOICE INVOLVED IN A POLICY
MOVING FORWARD TO HONOR THE.
ANCESTORS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU MISS FROM.
UP YOU KNOW. THE STATE OF THE-
HAS REALLY BECOME. A STORY
ABOUT THE- IT'S A STATE THAT
HAS PEOPLE THAT HAS BECOME A
STATE THAT IS SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE IT HAS PEOPLE FROM ALL.
REALLY ALL OVER THE WORLD OF
DIFFERENT FAITHS RELIGIONS AND-
AS MANY OTHER CALIFORNIANS I
HAVE. I SHARE BLOOD WITH MANY
OF THE GROUPS I AM NATIVE
AMERICAN. I AM OF SPANISH
ITALIAN EVEN NASH FOR **** JEW.
DISSENT AMONG MANY OTHERS. I
BELIEVE. HISTORY IN AMERICAN
HISTORY IN CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
TOLD IN CORRECTLY. IT'S BEEN
TOLD BY INDIVIDUALS THAT CAME
TO DOMINATE THE POLITICAL POWER
OF THE STATE IN THE COUNTRY
OVER THE YEARS I WASN'T A PARTY
TO THAT AND I'M NOT SUPPORTIVE
OF THAT. I THINK WE CAN CHANGE
THAT I THINK THIS BILL COULD
HELP US CHANGE THAT. AND WE
SHOULD CHANGE THAT. THIS BILL
ELIMINATES A REQUIREMENT TO
MAIN ONE MONUMENT AND REPLACES
IT WITH THE REQUIREMENT TO
MAINTAIN ANOTHER MONUMENT. AND
THE CONSTRUCTORS AND SIGNERS OF
THE NEW MONUMENT ARE ALREADY
SET- THAT THEY HAVE NO INTEREST
IN IN FEATURING WHO NEED BETTER
SAID ON THAT MONUMENT. AND AN
EGG AND EXPRESSLY- YOU KNOW I
DON'T REALLY BELIEVE. THAT WE
NEED TO DELETE PROVISIONS IN
OUR HISTORY IT'S- YOU KNOW
THERE ARE MANY FIGURES THAT
OFFEND- DIFFERENT PEOPLE I MEAN
WE HAVE ONE HERE IN OUR CHAMBER
THAT WAS A SLAVE OWNER AND OF
COURSE- YOU KNOW OUR HISTORY.
KEN IS VERY DARK AND THERE'S
PARTS O THE VERY DARK IN
ATLANTA AND THAT THAT THAT
NEEDS TO BE TOLD A LONG. WITH
THE SUCCESSES OF OUR HISTORY
AND HOW WE CAME TO BE HERE AND
HOW WE'RE ALL HERE. SHEREEN
JUST A BROAD RANGE OF. GENETIC
HISTORY. THAT IS MADE
CALIFORNIA A GREAT PLACE- I
THINK THIS BILL CAN. IN MAINE
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN THE COOPER
SEVEN MONUMENT AND A NEW
MONUMENT TO NATIVE AMERICANS
I'D LOVE FOR US TO SUPPORT THAT
THISTHIS BILL. COULD AUTHORIZE
THE CONSTRUCTION OF NATIVE
AMERICAN POT. MONUMENT AND I
WOULD I WOULD LOVE FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THAT. WITHOUT NECESSARILY. AND
I'M NOT SAYING PRESENT ON APRIL
SEVENTH- YOU KNOW I I'M JUST
THINKING WE SHOULD PRESENT ON
JUST LIKE ANY OTHER. A PORTENT
HISTORICAL FIGURE I THINK HE
WAS IMPORTANT IN HIS TIME. HERE
IN THE STATE HE ACTUALLY WALKED
BACKED TO MEXICO FROM MODERATE
FROM TWO FROM MONTEREY COUNTY
TO MEXICO CITY. TO PRESENT A
NATIVE AMERICAN BILL OF RIGHTS
BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR AT THAT
THAT THAT THEN GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA WAS ACTUALLY.
HORRIFICALLY ABUSING OF NATIVE
AMERICANS AND HE OPPOSED TO IT
HE BROUGHT IT UP WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND THE GOVERNOR DID
NOTHING TO CONTROL. THE
GARRISONS OF TROOPS ORDER WITH-
ACTUALLY BE ABUSIVE. AND SO HE
WENT BACK PERPER PRESENTED THE
BILL OF RIGHTS THEY WERE
ACTUALLY ADOPTED. AND THE
GOVERNOR WAS ACTUALLY REMOVED
FROM POWER BAIT BASED ON WHO
THE BETTER SAID US ADVOCACY FOR
NATIVE AMERICANS YES. HE WAS
INVOLVED IN OTHER THINGS BUT HE
ALSO. THE BELIEVED THAT THEY
DESERVE TO BE- RESPECTED BEN SO.
I THINK THAT THE STORIES TO BE
TOLD AND IT AND I AGREE THAT
ALL VOICES NEED TO BE HEARD IN
THIS TELLING OF HISTORY AND
THAT'S WHAT I'M SUPPORTING
TODAY. THAT WE- THAT WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS BILL AND I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO SEE ONE.
SMALL PROVISION LIMITED THERE'S
A LINE ON THE FIRST PAGE OF
SAID THIS BILL WILL DELETE THE
REQUIREMENT RELATED TO THE
MONUMENT OF CONVERTER SEVEN
THAT'S ALL I WOULD ASK. THAT BE
DELETED FROM THE BODY OF THIS
BILL. THEN IT BASICALLY LEAVES
THE ENTIRE BILL INTACT. THE
ENTIRE PROCESS AND THE WHOLE OF
CREATION OF A NEW MONUMENT AND
MAYBE IN FUTURE YEARS WE CAN
WORK TO PROVIDE SOME FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE. THROUGH THE
CREATION OF THIS MONUMENT SO
THAT IT CAN BE PROMINENT AND SO
THAT CAN BE. VERY INSTRUCTIVE
IN TELLING THE HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIAN I'D- I'D I'D MAKE A
MOTION THAT- THE BILL MOVE
FORWARD WITH THAT. AMENDMENT
AND- MAYBE ASK- MISTER CHAIR IF
THAT'S THAT WOULD BE MY MOTION.
IF WHAT TIME WILL WE RESPOND
MAKE SURE. PLEASE PROCEED TO
SEVEN HOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS- SENATOR
WESSEL AND IS GLAD TO BE HERE
YOU ACKNOWLEDGE THAT YOU HAVE
NATIVE AMERICAN BLOOD IN YOU.
AND OF THE NATIVE AMERICAN
BLOOD YOU SHOULD SEE THE WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO AS FAR AS
EDUCATING PEOPLE YOU TALK
ABOUT. SETTING HISTORY STRAIGHT
BUT UP UNTIL THIS POINT HAS
BEEN A PRINT TERMINAL APPROACH
TO TELLING THE HISTORY THAT
SOMEHOW THE CALIFORNIA INDIAN
PEOPLE ARE NOT EQUIPPED TO TELL
THEIR OWN STORY THAT IT'S A
PATERNAL APPROACH THAT WAS DONE
IN THE PAST THAT'S HOW THE ONE
PEDAL SEALED A STATUE GOT HERE
WHAT WE'RE ASKING IS FOR THAT
PATERNAL APPROACH TO BE
ELIMINATED FROM THIS POINT ON.
LET THE VOICE OF THE CALIFORNIA
INDIAN PEOPLE SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES IT'S NOT ABOUT
SITTING UP HERE TODAY AND
TAKING A MEMBER STRAIGHT FROM
THE DIETS WHICH I FEEL KINDA
HARD STYLE BUT I WILL COMMIT.
TO GETTING THIS BILL HERE AS IT
IS IN WORKING WITH YOU AND THE
SPONSORS IN A ROOM TO TALK
ABOUT WHY THERE IS SO MUCH
FRUSTRATION WITH THIS SYMBOLISM
OF ONE PANACEA IS IT RIGHT TO
CONTINUE TO KEEP SOMETHING UP
TO BRING SO MUCH HURT AND PAIN
AND TORMENT TWO OTHER PEOPLE
THAT FIRST INHABITED THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. I THINK THAT
GIVES DUE RESPECT TO THE PEOPLE
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
LET THEIR VOICE BE HEARD IN A
ROOM WE COULD TALK ABOUT THESE
AMENDMENTS RATHER THAN PUTTING
THEM UP ON THIS FLOOR AT THIS
TIME WHICH I DO AS FAR AS-
HIGHLY INAPPROPRIATE BUT I DO
COMMIT TO WORKING TO MOVE THE
FOOT MOVE FORWARD THESE ITEMS
BUT BRING PEOPLE INTO THE ROOM
TO DISCUSS THESE ISSUES. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER I. TAKE YOU
AT YOUR WORD I THINK I TRUCK
YOU IN- THINK YOU'RE- YOU'VE
BEEN A GREAT. IN I WOULD TO
LEAVE A AT THAT THAT'S ALL
POSSIBLE THAT YOU AGREE. TO
CONVENE A GROUP US WHERE SO.
AND OTHERS IN OTHERS WOULD LIKE
TO DO. BE IN THAT MEETING TO
DISCUSS THIS THIS PORTION OF
IT. AND IF THERE'S SOME
AGREEMENT THAT COMES OUT OF
THAT IT COULD BE. A MODIFIED-
YOU KNOW DOWN THE LINE IN
APPROPRIATIONS- BUT NOT IN THIS
COMMITTEE. THE- SIR GORGEOUS
SURELY I COULD FOLLOW UP ON
NINE YOUR COMMENTS- PASSIONS
CAN CERTAINLY RUN HIGH AND- I
ACTUALLY CONVERSATION WITH A
CONSTITUENT OF MINE AND THE
QUESTION WAS WOULD YOU WANT TO
SEE A STATUE OF ATATURK. ARE
IN- A PUBLIC SETTING IN THE
COURSE OF THE ANSWER IS
ABSOLUTELY NOT I WOULD TAKE
GREAT OFFENSE TO THAT- BUT MY
QUESTION. TO YOU AS YOU PROVIDE
INSTRUCTION TO THE AUTHOR ON
THE NEXT STEPS IN THE ASSUMING
THE AUTHOR AGREES TO THOSE NEXT
STEPS IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE
IS BEEN SOME SORT OF COMMISSION
OR MONUMENT COMMITTEE. EITHER
THROUGH RULES COMMITTEE HERE IN
THE SENATE WERE JOINTLY RATHER.
THAT LOOKS AT THAT THESE ISSUES
IN TOTALITY- THE STATUARY WE
HAVE. WE'RE. CALIFORNIA IN ITS
GOING THIS WOULD BE ENTIRELY
APPROPRIATE I WOULD SUSPECT TO
BE INCORPORATED INTO THOSE
DISCUSSIONS SO WHENEVER YOU DO
HAVE- THIS MEETING- MYSTERON
MOST. I WOULD LOVE IT IF YOU
COULD INCORPORATE INTO THAT
MEETING THAT YOU HAVE WHAT THE
STATUS IS OF THIS- MONUMENT
COMMITTEE OR MONUMENT
COMMISSION UNDER THE AUSPICES
OF- DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES IN THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE. WE'RE WITH THE- IF
THEY HAD HAD A REVIEW THIS
ISSUE ALREADY BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT VOICE WE
HAVEN'T HEARD ON- I THINK A LOT
OF FOLKS ARE GOING TO BE
LOOKING AT DIFFERENT STATUARY
DIFFERENT MONUMENTS IN WANTING
TO EXAMINE. DO THEY REFLECT OUR
REALITIES TODAY WITHOUT
FORSAKING THE BEAUTIFUL HISTORY
INS AND OFTEN TRAGIC HISTORY
THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED IN
CALIFORNIA I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
INCORPORATE THAT INTO YOUR
STATION SO THAT WHEN HE DOES.
FIND ITS WAY THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS PEOPLE CAN
SPEAK ADEQUATELY TO THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE OR NOT BEEN.
DONE IN THE STATUS OF IT MOVING
FORWARD. THANK YOU PERMISSION
OF A AS CHECK. PLEASE IT'S ME
MEMBER IN THE BILL IT IDENTIFY
THE DGS WOULD BE IN CHARGE OF-
REVIEWING THE PLANT IN
APPROVING THE PLANS THROUGH ON
THE PROCESS OF JOINT RULES SO
THE LEGISLATURE IS INVOLVED IN-
BE- THOSE ITEMS OF THE AGENDA
AS DURING THOSE MEETINGS. IS IT
WHICH IS NOT LIMITED JUST TO
THIS PARTICULAR. PIECE OF
STATUARY AND THE FORTHCOMING
NATIVE AMERICAN MONUMENT IT'S
WHERE DOES IT FIT IN THE
CALIFORNIA PROCESS- THAT SHOULD
BE IN PLACE AS WE REVIEW.
SIMILAR SITUATIONS. THANK YOU
FOR THAT MISTER CENTER MISTER
CHAIR BY MAY WE WILL- LOOK AT
THAT- AND SEE WHERE THAT FITS
WITHIN THE BILL CURRENTLY AT
THIS POINT. D. G. S. IS- DOES
IT REVEAL REVIEW THE PLANS AND
IT WOULD BE JOINT RULES IT
WOULD APPROVE BUT IF THERE'S
WAYS THAT WE CAN LOOK AT THAT.
AND PERHAPS- DISCUSS THAT EVEN
FURTHER WOULD BE MORE. THAN
HAPPY TO DO THAT MR CENTER.
OKAY ANY OTHER MEMBER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SEEING NONE DO I
SEEK TO HAVE A MOTION. WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR HUESO- THIS
THIS BILL IS A WELL SIR ROBERT
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR
THE MOTION- SENATOR WESSEL-
MAYBE THREE THREE EIGHT WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE CONSTRUCTION OF A
LONG OVERDUE MONUMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA TRIBES WHO CONTINUE
TO CALL THIS PLACE SACRAMENTO
HOME AND IT WILL BRING A LONG
OVERDUE END TO A MEMORIZATION
OF A MAN WHO SET FORTH THE
MENTALITY THAT FOLLOW THROUGH
THE HISTORY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA A TREATING
CALIFORNIA'S PEOPLE OFFERS
PEOPLE AS LESS. THAN HUMAN I
ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU
SO MEMBER- THIS- MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. SECRETARY CALLED THE
ROLL PLEASE DOT HI DONNA HI
NELSON. NELSON HI ALAN.
ARCHULETA BUT WHAT I'D- MAKE A
I BORDERS. BRADFORD OUR
BRADFORD I GLAZER PLEASE I WENT
SO I WAS SO CAN. CAN LONGER I
CAN LOG ON I AM THE IN THIS
PART OF NOW HI POINT YOU KNOW I
WOULD. THANK WILL I WILL HI HI.
THAT'S ELEVEN GERMAN ELEVENS-
BILL WILL BE PLACED A CALL
CENTER NUMBER ALMOST YOU VERY
SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIR CENTERS. OKAY WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NOW TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE. ABC SEVEN OH SIX
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TRULY IS SOON
AS THE PODIUM IS READY YOU- MAY
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY
TO PRESENT A B. SEVEN OH SIX.
THIS IS A TECHNICAL BILL
DEALING WITH THE WEST WING OF
THE STATE CAPITOL AND IT'S ONLY
INTENDED TO CLARIFY A POSSIBLE
AMBIGUITY IN THE LAW- IT'S GOOD
ACTUALLY WE'RE IN THE CHAMBERS
OF THIS FALL AS YOU KNOW WE
MOVE THE MEMBERSHIP INTO THE
SWING SPACE BUILDING- WE WILL
BE CONDUCTING OUR LIVES HAVE
SECTIONS AFFECTED JANUARY STILL
IN THESE. CHAMBERS OF THIS
CHAMBER TO ASSEMBLY CHAMBER.
PRESIDENT OF PROJECT MOVES
FORWARD THERE WILL BE A NEED
FOR SPACE ADJACENT TO THE
CHAMBERS. NOT IN THE ANNEX FOR
PURPOSES OF CAUCUSING. HOUSING
THE OFFICES OF THE CHIEF CLERK-
AND ALSO SERGEANT OFFICES. AND
THAT WILL RETAIL THAT WE MAKE
TEMPORARY CHANGES. TO
ACCOMMODATE THOSE USES IN THE
ANNEX ARE NOT PERMANENT
CHANGES. CONSTITUTIONALLY ANY
MODIFICATIONS TO THE WEST WING
FIRST SECOND OR THIRD FLOOR IS
EXISTED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO.
I NEED A NON EMERGENCY BILL TO
PROVIDE THAT AUTHORIZATION.
WE'VE ALREADY DONE THAT ON THIS
PROJECT THAT WAS DONE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. IN A. B. EIGHTEEN
TWENTY SIX. AND IT WAS- CHANGES
ARISE FROM AN AGREEMENT WITH
THE BROWN ADMINISTRATION. WE DO
EXPECT THAT AGREEMENT WILL BE
MODIFIED THIS BILL SIMPLY SAYS.
THAT THE AUTHORITY TO PROCEED
WITH THOSE CHANGES STILL
APPLIES EVEN IF WE MODIFY THE
INTERLINE AGREEMENT. SO IT'S
ACTUALLY A- TECHNICAL MEASURE-
ARM. AND- THAT IS ESSENCE OF
THE BILL AND IT DOES REFER.
INPUT FROM WHAT SHOULD COME
LAST ASKED TO PROVIDE A BILL-
JUST TO SUPPORT. THIS ONGOING
EFFORT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIMPLY
MEMBER NOW PULLED OUT OF A
MOVIE ANYONE WANTING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT I SEE NOBODY IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NO WITNESSES IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE- WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY- IN THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. SEVEN. OH SIX.
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB
SEVEN ZERO SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
BEGIN TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR
A. B. SEVEN ZERO SIX. FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY YOUR PERSONAL
SUPPORT FOR A. B. SEVEN AFFECT.
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES- IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN OH SIX I
SEE NONE IN THE GALLERY I SEE
NONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVEN OH SIX. THAT STRIKE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN OH SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE. FIRST
PARTICIPANT IS LINE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD FORTY NINE.
LINE FORTY NINE. MY NAME IS
ANDREA HAD STRUM AND I AM
CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
AB SEVEN OH SIX I'M CALLING IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO YOU
WASTING A BILLION DOLLARS THE
MALL IS SEEN A PERFECTLY GOOD
BILLION BUILDING WHEN PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE SUFFERING SO
MUCH THIS MAY BE JUST A
TECHNICAL BILL BUT IT IS
LEADING TO. SOMETHING THAT IS
SO HEINOUS AT THIS TIME IN
CALIFORNIA BUT I DON'T EVEN
KNOW HOW TO PUT WORDS TO IT
WHAT YOU LEGISLATORS ARE DOING
KEEPING THE PEOPLE OUT TAMALA
XINGMI ANNEX IS SO SNEAKY AND
SO DISGUSTING AND YOU'RE NOT
EVEN DEALING WITH THE REAL
ISSUES. I AM IN VERY STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE- AND- CAN YOU
KNOW BETTER DO THE RIGHT THING.
THANK YOU EXCELLENT LINE FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS RILEY A VOLUNTEER WITH
PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY FOR OUR
CAPITAL CLOSED EIGHTY SEVEN OF
SIX HERE'S WHY WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THE PROJECT HAS BEEN DEVELOPED
IN A VERY NON TRANSPARENT WAY-
YOU'LL HEAR THAT IT IS
TRANSPARENT BUT WE HAD
REQUESTED TO KEY DOCUMENTS
UNDER LAURA THAT HAVE BEEN
REFUSED TO ONE ONE BEING THE
AMMO YOU. THE OTHER BEING THE
PROJECT OVERVIEW IN SEQUENCING
REPORT- SO THAT IT'S NOT
TRANSPARENT IN OUR QUEUE. MS
COLE IDEA OF WHY THE BILL IS
OCCURRING WE WOULD LOVE TO KNOW
WHAT ARE THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED TO THE AGREEMENT THAT
IS THE M. O. U. ONCE AGAIN OUR
HR KEELING THAT THE AMENDMENT
THE REASONS FOR THE BILL R. AS
SECRET AS THE KEY REPORTS. AND
THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS IS
CONTROLLED BY THE MO U. THAT
WOULD SIGN BETWEEN- J. R. T.
FINANCE AND GENERAL SERVICES ON
NOVEMBER NINTH TWENTY NINETEEN
AND THAT MEANS THAT ALL THE
DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE BY A
THREE PERSON COMMITTEE
COMPRISED OF TWO LEGISLATORS
AND ONE GOVERNORS WERE.
MEETINGS ARE HELD IN SECRET
THERE ARE NO RECORDS OF THE
BOAT OR MEETINGS AVAILABLE TO
THE PUBLIC WE BELIEVE THAT THE
PROJECT HAS RESULTED FROM THE
SECRET SESSIONS WOULD SHOCK
MOST CALIFORNIANS THINGS WERE
MADE AWARE OF IT. WE FEEL THEY
WILL NOT BECOME AWARE OF IT
UNTIL THE DEMOLITION BEGINS
RELATED DESIGN CALLED FOR A
GLASS CLAD CRYSTAL PALACE
TOTALLY OUT OF KEEPING WITH THE
HISTORIC RESTORED CAPITAL AND
FOR THE WALK IN AT LEAST SIXTY
THREE CAPITAL PARK. WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE GOVERNOR LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR LEAD THE CAPITOL ANNEX
IN THE FEW MONTHS THERE IS TIME
TO RETHINK THE PROJECT TIME FOR
A PUBLIC PROCESS AND
FERMENTATION OF THE ANNEX WHICH
SHOULD BE ENOUGH COSTLY. TIME
CONSUMING AND PRESERVING THE
HISTORIC CAPITOL ANNEX AND
PRESERVING ALL THE TREES THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING TO OUR
CONCERNS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU TO VOTE NO ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
OF SIX. THANK YOU NOW THAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM. TWO SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION MORE TO ADD HOW
ANY OTHER CALLER TO STATE YOUR
NAME. OF AND- YOUR OPPOSITE.
OUR WILL NOT ALLOW SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE AHEAD. HI THIS IS
READ AMERICANS TREES SACRAMENTO
AND WE ALSO OPPOSE TO THE
SECRETIVE. THANKFULLY ISN'T
THANK YOU. WORK NEXT PLEASE.
ARE WE GOT THE QUEUE CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I REALLY
DO A BOTTLE COULD YOU THAT I
DID NOT. I JUST THAT WE HAVE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE NO MORE
COST TO THE WARM PUBLIC ON ALL
RIGHT WELL THAT WITHOUT- WE'RE
GOING TO- ASK ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS IF THEY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I SEE IT
WAS AT CENTER WAY SO FIRST-
OKAY SIR WE STILL MOVES- MISTER
COOLEY A SEVEN MEMBER COOLLY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
THANK YOU FOR THE EVER PRESENT
THIS BILL OBVIOUSLY THIS
PROJECT BEGAN UNDER GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER ONCE STUDIES
FUNDED BY BROWN. UNDER MY
PREDECESSOR WE HAVE HELD SEVEN
PUBLIC JOINT. RULES COMMITTEE
HEARINGS OVER THE YEARS AND
MAINTAINED A- ACCESS ON A
WEBSITE TO ABUNDANT INFORMATION
CONCERNING AVAIL- HI. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY BE PRESENT
HERE AND- TO JOIN YOU ON THOSE
DAYS WE GET ARTICLES THAT I
REQUEST AND I WILL THANK YOU
SIMPLY MEMBER THIS BILL'S BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER WAY SO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DOT OHIO. ONE SEVEN. MAYBE.
EXACTLY RESTATED OKAY
CURRENTLY- WE HAVE A TYPO HERE
SO THIS THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE FLOOR. NOW SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. DON BY
DOT HI NELSON OKAY YES I ALLEN.
OR TO HI ARCHULETA I'D BETTER.
ALL RIGHT BAKER I BOARDED I
WE'RE JUST BRADFORD ALL RIGHT
PREFERRED I GLAZER. BLAZER I
WAS. WETZEL I JOAN I DON'T I
CAN LONGER I CAN LOG I'M AT
LINDA'S. FOURTEEN TWENTY NO I
REALLY HI I AM KNOW WELCOME NO.
TWELVE TO A SEVEN IT'S TOO TO
ONE WILL PLAY SEVEN ON. MEMBERS
WILL NOW OPEN UP ROLE EVERY
BILL. WE'RE ONLY DO THIS ONLY
ONE WEEKLY PAY TO. WE'LL BEGIN
OUR CONSENT CAL SECTOR PLEASE
OPEN THE ON CONSENT. BABSON
MEMBERS ALAN. OUR ARCHULETA I'D
ALL RIGHT BAKER I BRADFORD ON
PREFER I JONES HI JOE I WILL.
BOOK TRIP THAT'S ONE ON. FOR TO
ONE THE CONSENT OUT. WE NOW
MOVE TO FILE I A NUMBER. ABC
SECTOR PLEASE OPEN ROLE ON A B.
THIRTY. THIS IS FAR HIM TO A.
B. THIRTEEN AND MY STATES. HI
.COM ARCHULETA HI. HI BECKER.
FOR JUST. BRADFORD WESSEL.
JONES NO JON SNOW CAN LONGER HI
YOUR MOTHER I MELINDA'S. RUBIO
HI I WILL NO WORK NO. AT
SEVENTY THREE CHAIRMAN ON CALL.
THAT'S SEVEN TO THREE WHAT
WOULD YOU SAY THAT WHEN I PUT
ON CALL. OKAY WE'LL PUT THE
BILL ON CALL. WE'LL NOW MOVE
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
EIGHTY FORTY SIX SECRETARY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE ON A. B.
FORTY SIX AFTER MEMBERS DON. I
DON HI ARCHULETA ALL RIGHT OR
TO A HI ORDERS. BRADFORD ALL
RIGHT FOR ALL RIGHT WHAT'S-
WHAT'S THE I. JONES NO KIM SNOW
CAMO. HI YOUR MOTHER I'M DOING
THIS NOW MELINDA'S NO RUBIO HI
WE ARE WE'LL. ELEVEN TO TRY
ROBERT CALL YEAH. LEVEL THREE
WILL PUT THAT BILL A CALL IT
JUST FOR THAT FOR THE RECORD
FOR THE- WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE
CAN SET ITEM- OPEN AS WELL. FOR
MEMBERS THAT- WE'RE HERE. TO
MOVE OUT TO- FOLLOW A MIRROR
FOR A SIX ONE SO PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE. DUGHTER HI DONNA HI
BORDERS. BORDERS I PRESS.
BRADFORD I WANT SOME ALL RIGHT
WAY SO I JONES KNOW JON SNOW
LONGER I CANNOT- I MILINDA.
MELENDEZ I. RUBIO I WILL. I'M
SORRY AS JONES NOT ONLY AS A
WITH JOE NOTED. GERMAN I IS
FIFTEEN ZERO OUT EVERY MINUTE
FIFTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
NOT MOVED BY A LOT OF NUMBER
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR ONE TWELVE
SECTOR PLEASE ALL THE ROLE ON
FOR TWELVE. THERE WERE TWO
SKEWS ME FROM SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
TWELVE ABSENT. SUPPORTERS
BRADFORD HI BRADFORD I WAS SO.
WESSEL I CAN LONGER I CAN
ISLAND. WELL KNOW RUBY. HI
RUBIO WILL. TWENTY THREE
CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD JUST NO
BORDERS NO. GOOD JOB THEIR
FORTUNES CAN AFFORD THAT IT'LL
BE ON CALL YEAH THE- NUMBER OF
THE FILE OR EIGHT EIGHTY NINE
ONE FIVE SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN.
THE ROLE ON NINE ONE FIVE- FABI
NINE ONE. ALAN BECKER ALAN
BAKER HI GORGEOUS GORGEOUS I
BRADFORD EFFORT I WANT SO. CAN
LONGER I AM NOT- R. I. MILAN S.
WILL BUY WELL HI. WHAT IS OUR
CHAIRMAN ACROSS A QUICK CALL
THAT AGAIN PLEASE SURE- THIS IS
FOLLOWED IN EIGHTY NINE ONE
FIVE ABSENT MEMBERS ALAN. ALLEN
HI WESSEL. WELL SO I MELINDA'S.
THAT IS FOURTEEN ZERO GERMAN
FOURTEEN ZERO THE BILLS OUT. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO FOLLOW NUMBER
NINE A. B. NINETY THREE
SECRETARYPLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
ON A. B. NINETY THREE TYPES OF
MEMBERS. BECKER HI BECKER HI
GORGEOUS YOU KNOW BORDERS NO
RAPPER. FRANKFURT WHEN SO I WAS
SO I CAN LOG HI CAN LOWER FINAL.
WILL HI WELL HI. ELEVEN TO
RETURN ONE OUR LEVEL THREE
BUILDS UP. NOW MOVE THE FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN A B. ILLETVE
TWENTY SECTOR PLEASE THE ROLE
ON A BELA TWENTY SO. AB LET
TWENTY THREE APPS MEMBERS
BECKER. BORDER I HOPE BECKER I.
BAKER ICE BORDER NO ORDER NO.
ON BRADFORD HI KEN LONGER. I AM
EITHER I IN THIS. AND THEN
THERE'S NO RUBIO. RUBIO I
WELCOME. THANKS FOR. A NUMBER
OF. THANK YOU FOR DOUBLE UP TO
FOR THAT BILL IS WILL NOW MOVE
TO FINALIZE NUMBER LET EIGHTY
THREE FIFTY EIGHT SECTOR OPEN
THE ROLE ON A B. TO EIGHT MAYBE
FIFTY EIGHT I SOME NUMBERS FOR
FROM ANOTHER. HI SPEC ON A
BOARD JUST. BRADFORD BRADFORD
ALL RIGHT WHAT SOME. ALL BUT SO
I CAN LOG HI I'M EITHER ON A
MAILING. WELL WELCOME I. TWELVE
TO CHAIRMAN OF OUT. TWELVE THE
ONE THE BILLS OUT- WILL NUMBER
THE FILE NUMBER TWO FOUR B. TH
THREE EIGHT SIX. PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE ON AB THREE THREE
EIGHT. THIS AB THREE THREE
EIGHT ABSENT MEMBERS ALAN. HEY
ALLEN FIVE BORDERS. JONES MORE
MELENDEZ. THOSE INTERESTED BUT
YEAH THAT'S TWELVE THEIR TERM.
TWELVE ZERO THAT FILLS OUT. NOW
MOVED TO FIVE ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN OH
SIX. EIGHTY SEVEN OH SIX ABSENT
MEMBERS ALAN. ALLEN HI THERE
FOURTEEN LISA ONE GERMAN. THAT
WOULD BE YOU KNOW. OKAY CAN WE
START BACK AT THE TOP. YES
STARTING WITH THE CONSENT SO
CONSENT ITEMS ABSENT MEMBER
ALAN HI ALAN HI THAT IS FIFTEEN
TWO ZERO THAT THOSE OUTCOMES-
BILLS OUT. IF YOU COULD JUST
ROLL DOWN THE ROLE PLEASE ON
THE- THE BILLS THAT ARE STILL
OPEN SURE OUR SERVICE IS AB
THIRTEEN FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO-
CHAIR BOARDING I'D FIGHTS ARE
VOTING NO ABSENT MEMBERS FACTOR.
pWESSEL HI MELENDEZ. AND THAT'S
IT. GERMAN AVAIL IS EIGHT TWO
THREE LEVELS OUT EIGHTY THREE
THAT BUILDS OUT. NEXT OPEN ITEM
IS FILE ITEM THREE A. B. FORTY
SIX ABSENT MEMBERS BORDERS.
WELCOME. AT ELEVEN TWO TWO
GERMAN ABOUT WAS ON THE BILLS
OUT ELEVEN THREE. OUR NEXT OPEN
ITEM IF ITEM. SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
TWELVE ABSENT MEMBERS. WELL.
BILLS AT TEN TEN FOR BILLS OUT.
AND FINALLY FILE ITEM. EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN.
ABSENT MEMBERS BRADFORD WHAT'S
SO. CAN LONGER I'M LIKE- I
MELENDEZ HI MELENDEZ I WILL. AT.
TWELVE THOUSAND. FOUR ZERO WHAT
WAS THE NUMBER TWELVE YEAH. THE
BILLS OUT. OKAY THANK YOU ALL
THE VERY INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU'RE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO OUR-
COMMITTEE WEBSITE- YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
PORT TO US WE WANT INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY THE FISHEL HEARING
RECORD. THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION THANKS FOR
ALL YOUR PATIENCE COOPERATION
THANKS TO THE- MODERATOR AND
STAFF- WE'VE INCLUDED SUITED
THE AGENDA FOR TODAY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION IS NOW WHAT YOU'RE.